Oh, ein bisschen groß, die Emotes.
Excellent Streaming.
Er ist mal im Weinkeller gewesen.
Ich habe euch ja gestern mal
einen Weinkeller im Stream gezeigt.
Excellent Weinkeller.
Äh.
Mal kurz mein Mikrofon rausziehen.
Kurz das Mikrofon rausziehen.
Da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Excellent Mikrofon.
Jetzt stimmt wieder alles. Sehr gut.
Ähm. Hat Twitch gecheckt,
dass wir online sind? Ich hoffe mal.
Ja, ja, ja. Angeblich, angeblich.
Hat das, äh, das alles, alles klar.
Ja. Starts.
Ähm. Keine Frametrops.
Das ist schon mal
sehr nice.
Excellent. Leute, ich habe den,
ich, ich, ich zeige euch jetzt gleich
den, den
big brainigsten Windows-Hack,
den ihr seit langem gesehen habt.
Gleich, gleich,
weil mehr Leute da sind.
Der ist, der ist Poggers,
Pog, Pogchamp
und, äh, Pfeiffer zusammen.
Was ich euch gleich zeige.
Der ist, der ist wahrlich
excellent.
Zeige ich euch. Aber vorher zeige ich euch noch mal was anderes.
Und zwar, Chat, ich sehe euch kurz nicht.
Ich muss refreshen.
Hallo an alle, die schon da sind.
Ich habe gerade den Chat refreshed. Ich habe gesehen, es haben schon ein paar Leute
reingeschrieben. Schön, dass ihr alle am Start seid.
Ähm.
Was ist die Lautstärke?
Ähm. Ähm. Ticken, ticken leiser können wir noch machen.
Ein Ticken
leiser. So.
Ja gut, das muss jetzt erstmal
anfangen, wupp, wupp, wupp zu machen.
Also, passt mal auf, Leute. Ich habe was gemacht.
Khm, khm, khm.
Ähm.
Ich habe was gemacht, das gehört sich eigentlich nicht.
Also, sowohl als
Gamer, als auch
als Informatiker.
Passt das, passt das nicht. Ja.
Und zwar war ich
vorhin unter Wasser.
Im Bad.
Und ich habe hier mein Dashboard mit der Heizung.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal zusammen an.
Das ist nämlich das quasi, das was wir
gestern und vor, vorgestern im Stream gebaut haben.
Jetzt fertig.
Und guckt euch mal mein schönes
Heizung da, ähm, Handy Games.
Oh ne, ne. So tief bin ich auch noch nicht gesunken.
Guckt euch mal mein schönes
Dashboard an für die Heizung.
Ist das nicht
Next Level
Exquisite.
Man sieht die Wassertemperatur.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, wann ich duschen
gewesen bin.
Räum mal lieber das Windows aus wozu.
Da stört das nicht, dass es ein paar
Icons auf dem Desktop hat.
Was meint ihr, wo ich duschen gewesen bin?
Man sieht es. Man kommt
gar nicht drauf, ja. Natürlich
hier. Also sprich,
die Temperatur ist runtergegangen
bis auf 16,4 Grad.
So um
17 Uhr 43 oder so.
Im gleichen Maß ist der,
äh, äh, äh, der Brenner
wie verrückt an und aus
gegangen.
Und, ähm, zur gleichen Zeit sind
glaube ich die Abgas, äh,
die, ähm, Temperatur
vom, vom, von den Abgasen
ist raufgegangen
auf irgendwie an die 70 Grad.
Also
das hat, das hat wirklich
volle Pulle.
Hast du das gebaut?
Das Dashboard. Ja gut, das Dashboard an sich
ist Grafana, aber die, die,
die Auswertung habe ich gebaut, ja.
Ist gar nicht so einfach. Raspberry Pi, äh,
an den, an die Heizung angeschlossen.
Ähm, was drauf installiert?
Custom Software, die da draußen
Prometheus-Exporter macht und dann
Prometheus in Grafana rein.
Aber hier sieht man schon, funktioniert wunderbar.
Die Pumpe hat in der ganzen Zeit nicht gepumpt.
Witzigerweise.
Ähm, ich glaube auch,
ich glaube entweder, dass die Heizung
zu schwach für das ganze Haus ist, aber das kann ja nicht sein.
Einfach beim Duschen. Ähm,
ich, ich, ich glaube das Ding ist,
dass irgendwie Fail konfiguriert.
Weil ich würde eigentlich erwarten,
dass wenn ich dusche, dass
der Brenner einfach volle Pulle brennt.
Für Viertelstunde oder so.
Muss mir grad mal was
aufschreiben, sonst vergesse ich das wieder.
Ups.
So. Ähm,
so sieht's aus. Gut. Ähm, aber damit
beschäftigen wir uns heute nicht.
Wollte euch bloß mal zeigen,
wie schön das Ganze funktioniert.
Man kann hier auch umstellen, zum Beispiel
die letzten 15 Minuten sieht man das, oder,
die letzten 3 Stunden. Also es ist
eindeutig, wo ich mich unter das Wasser
gestellt habe, oder?
Vorher alles normal und dann
und dann, als ich
hier fertig war. So, guck mal mal,
guck mal mal, wie lange ich, wie lange ich unter dem Wasser
war. Ich würde mal sagen, hier so ungefähr hat's angefangen.
Bis, äh,
wahrscheinlich bis so
da, bis es wieder hoch geht.
Wie lange habe ich unter dem Wasser gestanden? Irgendwie
eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten oder so.
Es kommt, kommt ungefähr hin.
Exzellent.
Das sollte aber auf jeden Fall
nicht so sein.
Das Kleingeschick, oh ja, da hast du recht.
Das, das, das müssen wir fixen.
Ähm, Sign-In.
Das müssen wir tatsächlich fixen.
Das gefällt mir auch nicht.
Äh, Moment, wo war das
nochmal hier? Ok.
Ah, yes.
Exquisite, exquisite.
Safe. Ah, jetzt muss ich das Dashboard
neu exportieren in, in, in,
oder? Ist das, ist der Hash-Wert
der gleiche geblieben? Ich hoffe mal.
Zumindest, ähm, die Sache gucken wir uns
heute nicht, nicht näher an. Ich wollte es euch bloß nochmal
zeigen, dass das wunderbar
funktioniert, was wir da so die letzten
Male gebastelt haben. Ich muss mal
gerade mein Kabel ein bisschen entwirren.
So.
Also, ne, seht ihr, das funktioniert richtig gut.
Hast du schon das Path of Exile
Leak-Announcement gesehen? Ne.
Wo ich eben geguckt habe, vor einer Stunde
war noch nichts da. Echt?
Wo?
Hast du mal einen Link? Wo, wo, wo ist das?
Ich meine, irgendwo hier muss das ja drinnen stehen.
Mega-Leak. Weiß ich nicht,
mal gucken. Official Trailer,
oh, das müssen wir uns, das müssen wir uns kurz mal
angucken.
Moment, das ist doch gar nicht,
das ist doch, das ist aber nichts Offizielles,
ne?
Oder, ist das irgendein
Leak? Oder wie? Weil das ist nicht
die offizielle Path of Exile,
das ist irgendein Fake, oder?
Das ist doch irgendein Fake.
Das wollte ich mir mal kurz angucken, dann fangen wir an
mit der Windows-Geschichte.
Als alter Path of Exile-Grinder.
Oh, das sieht
legit aus, das sieht legit aus, das sieht nicht
äh, zusammengefakt hat.
Es ist nebelig?
Es ist nebelig? Es ruckelt, das Spiel ruckelt
noch nicht genug.
Ne, das ist die neue Path of Exile-Leak.
Gibt's ja alle
drei Monate, gibt's was Neues immer.
Also, okay,
es ist nebelig.
Das erkenne ich schon mal.
Oh, Moment, was war das da gerade?
Wat?
Add Six Paths? Oh!
Kann man die Skills
jetzt selbst auswählen?
Was ist an dem Game so gut? Das ist
das beste Action-RPG,
was es gibt zur Zeit.
Da kann Diablo 3 einpacken.
Aha.
Das sieht
ziemlich OP aus.
Ah!
Wenn man das sockelt, kriegt man
quasi nen Add-On auf seinem Skill-Tree irgendwie.
Oh, das ist, das ist cool.
Oh, das gibt es, es ist ja nicht so, als hätte Path of Exile
nicht eh schon 30 Billiarden Varianten, was man spielen kann.
Jetzt sind's halt 50 Billiarden Varianten.
Oh, das ist nice.
Ich spiel aber eh wieder Noob-Summoner-Klasse, wenn sie das nicht nerven, da brauch ich das alles nicht.
Okay, den Kram gibt's immer noch.
Oder ist jetzt wieder neu?
Moin, Doki.
Ah, Doki, ich muss dir was zeigen.
Jetzt, wo du grad da bist.
Heizung, alles hier
huge eingerichtet.
Boah, das sieht cool aus.
Developer-Commentary.
Hi, I'm Chris Wilson from Grinding Gear Games.
Touch the mirror of Delirium and your nightmares will manifest as reality.
Das ist so ne neue
Rift-Geschichte oder sowas in der Richtung,
ha?
Existing enemies gain terrifying abilities.
Also, bisschen wie diese, diese, diese,
diese roten Portale, die's schon gibt.
Plunge deeper into the Delirium to seek deadlier terrors and even greater rewards.
Delirium affects all Path of Exile content to greatly increase its risk and return.
Consume orbs of Delirium to put entire maps into a state of Delirium.
Oh, das ist cool.
Das heißt, das ist im Prinzip einfach Content mal 2 im Endeffekt, weil man kann alles bisherige spielen mit dem neuen Mod.
Das ist nice.
Wie weit bist du mit dem Heizungs-Dashboard?
Das wollte ich euch, das hab ich euch grad schon gezeigt, aber ihr wart nicht im Stream.
Ich zeig das gleich nochmal.
Combine splinters from these maps to reveal Deliriums mysterious endgame encounter.
Grow your passive skill-tree by placing cluster jewels in its albemore stock.
Wie neue Endgame? Ist, ist Sirius nicht mehr, äh, der Letzte jetzt.
Craft these jewels to improve their passives.
Add one of 280 new notables, or graft the...
Der Sirius-Fight is easy as fuck als Summoner.
...additional sockets and exclusive keystone passives.
...add additional sockets and exclusive keystone passives.
Das sieht sehr nice aus. Wann geht die League los?
Ich brauch das Startdatum.
Da wird gegrindet.
Da wird der Hardcore-Grind gemacht.
Experience Delirium on Friday the 13th of March.
Ooooh. Also nur 14 Tage.
Nein, ein bisschen länger.
Drei Wochen.
Da sind wir dabei.
Genau, also, hier.
Heizungs-Dashboard.
Ähm.
Alles schon eingerichtet, funktioniert mittlerweile.
Eine Sache, die sehr merkwürdig ist, man sieht's.
Ich muss gerade mal die Sache ein bisschen erweitern auf drei Stunden.
Also ich hab hier die Soll-Temperatur vom Wasser,
die aktuelle Wassertemperatur,
ob das Ding einen Fehler meldet,
was der Brenner so macht,
und die Abgastemperatur,
und auf wie viel Prozent die Pumpe läuft.
Was natürlich sehr merkwürdig ist,
Vielleicht kann Herr Doxy was dazu sagen, wenn er die Dinger einbaut.
Hier bin ich, hier habe ich unter dem Wasser gestanden.
Hier war ich unter der Dusche und das warme Wasser ist übelst getroppt in der Zeit.
Und zeitgleich, man sieht jetzt leider, ich habe den Graph hier ein bisschen verkackt,
zeitgleich, das ist ungefähr hier so, zeitgleich ist der Brenner wie verrückt am An- und Ausgehen.
Also ich hätte jetzt hier eigentlich erwartet, wenn ich warm Wasser quasi aus der, ja, entnehme,
ja, ja, ja, wenn ich warm Wasser entnehme, hätte ich jetzt eigentlich erwartet,
dass der volle Pulle läuft oder halt durchgängig läuft.
Macht er aber nicht.
Gucken, ob wir das verschieben können, dann sieht man es besser.
Ich habe halt gedacht, Brenner-Statistik juckt nicht so sehr.
Guck.
Zu der Zeit, jetzt sieht man es ja gut, ne, zu der Zeit, ähm, und ich schiebe mal die
Abgaswerte unten drunter, ja, äh, zu der Zeit, wo ich hier duschen gewesen bin, ist
der Brenner, hat, ist übelst an-aus, an-aus, an-aus, an-aus gegangen, ähm, die ganze
Zeit, aber die Abgaswerte waren...
Auch so, auch so, nicht so, nicht so hoch an der, in der Zeit.
Der Brenner macht das gerade auch.
Ja, aber vorher hat er das nicht gemacht.
Vorher hat er durchgängig 32% gemacht, die ganze Zeit.
Ich hätte eigentlich erwartet, wenn ich mich unter die Dusche stelle und warm Wasser anmache,
dann, äh, gibt er Gas.
War die Einrichtung vom Heizungsstöcker kompliziert?
Du kannst dir einfach die letzten zwei Streams angucken, da sieht man es.
Das ist die Temperatur.
47 Grad, das ist, das ist definitiv die Temperatur.
Ich zeig das mal meinem Heizungsmann.
Ich hab jetzt ja die ganze Statistik, die ganze Statistik gelockt.
Ich hab ja die ganze, ich hab ja die ganze Statistik da.
Das zeig ich dem mal und dann, dann kann er sich ja überlegen, äh, was er dazu, was
er dazu sagt.
So Leute, aber heute machen wir was anderes und ich hab euch gesagt, ich zeig euch den
krassesten Windows-Headset.
Hack aller Zeiten, also Sixthead-Wine-Premium-Extrem.
Also mehr, mehr geht nicht.
Kennt ihr das?
Ihr wollt beispielsweise eine Windows-ISO runterladen, weil ihr jetzt es in Windows
installieren wollt.
Das muss man nämlich jetzt machen, weil ich wäre diese alternativen Desktops für Windows,
die wäre ich garantiert nicht auf meinem richtigen Windows installiert.
Das machen wir jetzt schön in der VM.
Ähm, liest du das mit einem extra Stecker und einem extra Programm oder kann man theoretisch für alle
halten?
Also das, was ich hab, geht nur für Wiesmann.
Es gibt bestimmt für die meisten Heizungen andere Sachen.
Ich hab so ein Ding gekauft, das ist so ein Wiesmann-Stecker auf USB und, ähm, da hinten
ist ein Raspberry Pi dran mit einer Software von GitHub, die Leute, wo Leute das Wiesmann-Zeug
nachprogrammiert haben und, äh, da, da funktioniert, da funktioniert es auf Anhieb.
Ähm, was ich dazu gebaut hab, ist, ich hab quasi um diese Software noch einen Prometheus-Exporter
rumgestrickt, dass ich das Ganze in Grafana kriege.
Den haben wir gestern programmiert und eingerichtet und ich glaub zwei Streams vorher haben wir
auf dem Raspberry Pi die Heizung eingerichtet.
Also wenn es dich interessiert, kannst du einfach die letzten, letzten zwei Streams gucken, wo es um die Sache ging.
Prometheus ist ein Tool, was, äh, Statistiken und Metriken sammelt und im Prinzip ist Grafana nur die
Oberfläche, die das Ganze anzeigt.
So, ja, zum Beispiel, ich hab hier Prometheus, exportiert bei mir hier VitoDense, diese Sachen
exportiert das, das, das ist halt, was mein Programm macht im Endeffekt, diese Sachen
zu exportieren.
Das Tool auf GitHub hat keine grafische Oberfläche.
Moment, Moment, das Tool, von dem ich auf GitHub rede, ist das hier.
Das ist nur dafür da, das Wiesmann-Protokoll zu verstehen.
Achso, ähm, äh, wie viel ich brauche?
Achso, ähm, ähm, äh, wie viel ich brauche?
Äh, wie viel ich brauche, habe ich nicht so ganz, äh, gecheckt, ich kann dir aber sagen,
was es ist.
Es ist eine VitoDense 2.2.2, steht drauf.
Was ich verbrauche, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe nur nachgeguckt, was ich für eine Heizung habe.
Aber die, wird, also irgendwas kann da nicht stimmen, das Verhalten, das Verhalten ist
irgendwie sehr, sehr wirr.
Genau, das Ding ist das, was, ähm, das Wiesmann-Protokoll kann.
Mit dem, was ich, was ich verbrauche, muss ich mal gucken, das habe ich jetzt noch nicht
auf die Schnelle gefunden, alles.
Ähm.
Ich habe dieses Wiesmann-Protokoll auf dem Raspberry Pi kapiert und mein Programm geht
an diesen V-Control D und liest die, die Werte aus.
Exportiert das als, äh, Prometheus-Metriken und, äh, Prometheus lese ich dann im Grafana
ein.
Die Abgastemperaturen sind auch so hoch, ja.
Ich werde es dem mal zeigen.
Das Gute ist, dass ich jetzt ja die Statistiken dazu habe und das kann ich ihm einfach zeigen.
Da sage ich einfach, hier, guck mal, guck mal hier, wenn ich duschen gehe, bam.
Äh.
Wie kann man das jetzt machen, dass der Docker-Container die Settings beibehält?
Du musst ein Volume angeben.
Du stellst in deinem Docker-Compose-File ein Volume und sagst, welches lokale, welcher
lokale Ordner, äh, wo quasi im Container gemountet werden soll.
Da steht bei jedem jeweiligen Container dabei, welcher Ort das sein muss im Container.
Also das ist, äh, alles andere als...
Gut, also fangen wir jetzt mal an.
Ich wollte euch ja den krassesten Windows-Hack aller Zeiten zeigen.
Äh.
Also, zum Beispiel, wenn man hier sowas ausprobieren will, ähm, quasi alternative Oberflächen
für Windows und das nicht in seinem, auf seinem Windows machen will, dann installiert
man sich in der Regel ja eine VM.
So.
Und wenn man sich eine VM installieren kann, braucht man ein Windows-ISO.
Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn man ein Windows-ISO runterladen will bei Microsoft, dann geht
das nicht.
Dann muss man sich das Media Creation Tool runterladen und dann kann man das lokal erstellen.
Aber, jetzt passt mal auf.
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Äh.
Fadil...
Was?
Fadil Kini?
Zwei Monate.
Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
So.
Was man einfach machen muss, ist entweder den User-Agent umstellen auf Mac, auf Safari,
aber es geht viel einfacher.
Es geht viel einfacher.
Ihr macht die, ihr macht die, äh, Tools auf, die, Moment, ich muss das mal kurz auf die
anderen Seite schieben.
Ihr macht die Developer-Tools auf.
Und stellt einfach...
Und stellt einfach auf Mobile-Device um.
Äh.
Und dann refresht ihr die Seite und schon könnt ihr runterladen.
Ist das nicht nice?
Microsoft Security 2020.
Das ist doch mal hier, Eleven Head.
Microsoft-Mitarbeiter hassen diesen Trick.
Wofür dann überhaupt das Tool?
Weil Microsoft wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Daten über dich sammeln will oder so.
Geil.
Schimmer.
So.
Ich hab extra...
Ich hab extra Platz gelassen auf der Platte oder wir nehmen die SSD, eins von beiden.
Die zweite SSD.
Ist User-Friendly das Tool?
Naja, einfach runterladen finde ich ehrlich gesagt User-Friendlier als so ein komisches
Tool installieren zu müssen.
So.
Wir müssen jetzt noch 3 Minuten warten.
Kann ich mal gucken, ob ich im Chat...
Ähm.
Media Creation Tool läuft nur als ernsthaft.
Ich hab schon lange kein Media Creation Tool mehr gestartet.
Egon, da haben wir ein eigenes Kommando für.
Ich glaub Ausrufezeichen 1 oder so.
Ich probier's mal aus.
Da hab ich das mal erklärt, warum ich da so meinen Copy-Paste-Tick habe mit 1.
So.
Ich guck jetzt mal den Chat durch, während das runterlädt.
sich verarscht von Microsoft. Wieso? Weil du
immer das mit dem Media Creation Tool machst.
Viel Glück, woher kommst du? Aus Hanau.
Glaube ich nicht, dass
du das bist.
Oh, stimmt, wir haben jetzt ja den Wendler, den Wendler
Flick als Emote.
Ricardo Flick ist out.
Wendler Flick ist in.
Wo das ist? Hanau
ist da, was
vor letzte Woche,
also bei Frankfurt, das ist da, wo der Typ
Amok gelaufen ist vor ein paar Tagen.
Und gestern in der
Nähe, in Kassel, in der Nähe in Hessen
auch der Typ in den Karnevalsumzug
gefahren ist.
Oh, der Scam Train. Leute,
94% Hype Train.
Oh mein Gott, der Hype Train.
Huge.
Gebt Twitch alle euer Geld.
Auch liebevoll
genannt, der Scam Train.
Scam-Ass-Train.
Und wenn ihr mich jetzt
habt, kriegt ihr Zugriff,
auf sagenhafte
in Worten, 4
Emotes
von
24 möglichen Emotes.
Ganze 4.
Ich muss mich echt mal, bei der Gelegenheit
muss ich das ja dann immer anmerken, ich muss mich echt
langsam mal wieder um neue Emotes
kümmern. Wie gesagt, wir haben 20
Emote-Slots noch frei.
Und wenn man schon gesappt hat, dann bist du eh
in der Abo-Falle, dann ist vorbei.
Ah, hier.
Okay, Installer.
Die Installation ist durch.
So.
Dann legen wir mal eine Windows 10
vor einmal an und probieren den ganzen Mist
mal aus. Custom.
Workstation. Ich installiere
selbst. Windows 10.
Jawoll.
Next. Next.
Äh.
4 Kerne. Next.
Windows braucht das.
4096 RAM. Windows braucht
ordentlich RAM.
Nut. Jawoll.
Excellent.
60G. Machen wir mal 40G. Komm.
Windows wird doch mit 40G auskommen.
Oder was meint ihr? 40G?
Könnte knapp werden.
Finish.
So, jetzt nochmal schnell, nochmal schnell
den Drucker entfernen.
Drucker. Wo ist der Drucker? Der muss weg.
Und die
Soundkarte machen wir...
Na, mal gucken. Vielleicht lassen wir die dran.
Äh, Accelerate 3D Graphics. Blablabla.
Blablabla.
Auf geht's.
Äh. Was?
SATA 01.
Ich hab die VM gerade angelegt. Was hat der denn jetzt schon wieder
für Schmerzen?
Ach so. Ah.
Ja, weil... Ha! Use Physical Drive.
Welches Physical Drive?
Ich hab nicht mal ein CD-Laufwerk dran.
Okay, mal gucken, ob unser
Windows 10 ISO funktioniert.
Ist VMware performanter als VirtualBox?
Ach, ich glaube, das nimmt sich
nicht so viel. Ich finde, VMware
wäre aber insgesamt deutlich angenehmer.
Nicht Attached. So, nochmal neu starten.
So. Jetzt müssen wir uns
erstmal die BigBrain
Windows-Installation geben.
Da kommen wir jetzt nicht drum rum.
Also erstmal
im Schnelldurchgang Windows.
Äh. Language to install
Currencies.
Nee, nee, nee. Time and Currency
machen wir schon auf Deutsch. Sonst haben wir die ganzen
Kokona-Einheiten drin. Das wollen wir garantiert
nicht.
Da haben wir dann
BTU und Fahrenheit und solche
komischen Dinger.
Aber bitte Pro. Natürlich Pro.
Was sonst? Kann man das noch
auswählen?
I don't have a product key.
Ah, hier. Pro.
Natürlich. Windows 10
Pro. Von Pros
für Pros.
Windows bräuchte mal einen Live-USB-Stick.
Ja, tatsächlich. Ich hatte mal
ein Windows-PXE-Boot.
Windows-Rescue-System-PXE-Boot.
Hab ich aber nie
benutzt und dementsprechend ist das komplett
out.
Und ich glaube, es läuft gar nicht mehr.
Upgrade. Custom install.
Next.
Okay, jetzt installiert der Kram.
Leute, der Hype-Train.
15 Sekunden noch und keiner ist
keiner hat den Scam-Train mitgemacht.
Was ist mit euch los?
Der Chat.
Wenn man sich auf den Twitch-Chat verlässt, ist man
echt verlassen.
Der Scam-Train.
Er überliest mich auch. Echt?
Kann ich überlesen?
Wo denn?
Achso, ich drücke dir die Daumen mit deinem Klempner.
Wenn da so ein Alter kommt, sind die meisten
mit der neuen Technik überfordert und genervt, wenn das
alles lockt. Ja, dann hat er Pech.
Ich kann ja mit meiner Heizung locken, was er will,
was ich will.
Nee, so schlimm sind die nicht.
Cute-Chat ist zu Big-Brain für den
Scam-Train. Ja,
ich glaube, mit dem kann man reden.
Und wenn nicht, ganz ehrlich, es gibt ja
noch andere. Irgendjemand hat
was gefragt mit Virtual Box.
Eben.
Achso, Quatsch mit Soße hat noch was
gefragt. Hast du schon das Video, in dem du dein
Linux so einrichtest, wie du es benutzt
erstellst? Oder machst du das noch?
Wir machen das im Livestream fertig. Wir hatten ja mal
angefangen. Hat der Pfeiffer-Typ
schon? Klar, das haben wir uns doch sogar schon mal angeguckt
im Stream.
Also, zu der Frage,
die eben, ich finde sie leider nicht mehr.
Zu der Frage mit
Virtual Box oder
VMware. Ich glaube,
Performance-mäßig ist es nicht so ein großer
Unterschied. Ich denke aber, dass
VMware vom Unterbau her und von den
Features moderner ist. Virtual Box
ist so auf Sparflamme bei Oracle.
Zumindest hat man
so den Eindruck. Und
Virtual Box ist halt
vom User-Interface und von der, wie sagt man so
schön, von der User-Experience
halt deutlich nicer als
Virtual Box. Das ist auch der Grund, warum
ich VMware habe. Also Workstation.
Nicht Player. Player gäbe es auch noch.
Aber ich finde
VMware Workstation tatsächlich mal
was, wo der Preis,
zumindest wenn man es sich an Weihnachten immer
in ihrem Sale kauft, schon
gerechtfertigt ist.
Och nee, Leute. Fuck, wisst ihr was? Jetzt kommt Cortana.
Jetzt kommt gleich Cortana.
Gleich kommt Cortana.
Bist dich
alle. Genau.
Hi, I'm Cortana.
Ich ziehe Cortana einfach die Soundkarte raus.
Sollte
Cortana anfangen zu schwätzen,
ziehe ich die Soundkarte raus.
Keo-Kun, mir ist es ein Rätsel, wie du
in dieser Aussage jetzt irgendwas
in dieser Richtung
erkannt hast. Just a moment.
So. Also wir haben
zur Auswahl, die Musik
kann sich heute nicht entscheiden, ob sie laut
oder leise sein will.
War noch ein Stückchen laut und es ist immer gerade zu laut.
Also was wir heute
ausprobieren, wenn Cortana
da
in Senf abgelassen ist. Also ich will
ein paar Sachen ausprobieren. Es gibt verschiedene Varianten.
Es gibt einmal hier mit Cairo-Shelso,
sowas. Da habe ich letztens ein Video zu gesehen.
Das ersetzt komplett alles
unter Windows an Oberfläche.
Also sprich den
Desktop,
die Startleiste und
den Explorer. Also das sieht komplett anders aus.
Wie geht es der Katz?
Der geht es gut.
Habe ich ein Bild eigentlich von da?
Ich habe hier gar keinen.
Aber ich habe
hier ein Bild.
Da ist er. Der geht es gut.
Also das ersetzt alles bei Windows.
Dann will ich das hier mal ausprobieren.
Das ist ein Tiling
Window Manager für
Windows. Ich verwende ja unter
Linux auch nur Tiling Window Manager.
Da habe ich allerdings
nicht so große Hoffnungen drin, weil das ist eben
ein Auto-Hotkey-Skript. Mal gucken,
ob das so funktioniert. Probieren wir dann noch aus.
Und als letztes will ich mir mal die aktuelle
Entwicklung angucken. Oder keine Ahnung, welche
Reihenfolge wir das machen. Von OpenShell.
OpenShell ist quasi nur ein
alternatives Startmenü.
Aber als erstes, und hier bin ich wirklich mal gespannt,
drauf probiere ich mal das Ding hier aus.
Für was den
kompletten Windows-Desktop austauscht.
Oh.
Region ist korrekt. Germany.
Yes.
Is this right keyboard?
No.
Kann man da eigentlich tippen?
Nee.
German. Yes.
Moment, Leute.
Habe ich
gerade aus Versehen die Sprache umgestellt?
Kann das sein? Nee, oder?
Skipp.
Ich will die Sprache auch auf Englisch
lassen.
Ich will das ganze Ding auf Englisch lassen und bloß die Tastatur
auf Deutsch. Wisst ihr noch, was es
letztes Mal für ein riesen Akt war?
Englisches Windows und deutsche
Tastatur?
Gucken, ob das jetzt einfacher geht als
letztes Mal. Excellent.
Just a moment.
Wie oft der Kram neu
startet und macht und hoot, alter.
Now
let's see what's new from Windows.
Eigentlich
will ich das überhaupt nicht sehen.
Okay. Setup for personal use.
Jetzt kommt's drauf an. Jetzt wollen sie uns
gleich den Microsoft-Account aufschwätzen.
Jetzt wollen sie uns gleich...
Offline-Account. Das ist so
richtig versteckt.
Limited experience.
Und jetzt darf man
sich den lokalen Account
anlegen.
Tests. Next.
1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6.
Oh, even better. Online-Account.
Ich weiß nicht, welche
ähm, doch
in der Pro-Version Chillfreak
ist er noch dabei.
Ähm, ich versteh nicht, warum
ein Offline-Account eine
limited experience ist.
Security-Question.
Kann man das überspringen?
Al...
1.
Ah, ne.
1. Perfekt.
Ähm.
Nein. No.
No.
Basic.
Das ist toll, ne?
Send diagnostic data zu Microsoft.
Ich kann entweder auswählen,
full oder basic.
Off gibt es nicht.
Off existiert von Microsoft nicht.
Ich möchte nichts an Microsoft schicken.
Steht nicht zur Diskussion.
Basic.
No.
Was für eine Scheiße, oder?
Bei Enterprise gibt es... Ah, okay.
Ich habe noch nie ein Enterprise Windows installiert.
Ich hoffe, ich komme auch drum herum.
Everything ready for you.
Ich bin ja schon ganz aufgeregt.
This may take several minutes.
Das ist G-Bait.
Das dauert 10 Sekunden, oder so.
Wo ist Cortana?
Anscheinend bei der Installation nicht mehr dabei.
Du kannst das skippen mit Ctrl-Alt.
Quatsch.
Ernsthaft? Warum?
Warum sollte ich es mit Ctrl-Alt entfernt skippen können?
Echt?
Dann ist alles auf Default.
Und Default ist bestimmt an.
Probier mir jetzt nicht aus.
Guck mal.
Seht ihr, wie der Bildschirm hin und her wackelt?
Dass es so aussieht, als macht er was.
Ah ja.
Welcome to your Microsoft Edge Startpage.
Ja.
Edge brauchen wir nicht.
Gut.
Das erste, was wir jetzt machen müssen, ist Fiber Tools installieren.
Und dann geht es los.
Install Fiber Tools.
Weg.
Fiber Tools.
Yes.
Stretch machen wir aus.
Up.
Hallo.
Weiter drücken.
Typical Install.
So, dann müssen wir Restarten und dann sollte es im Fullscreen alles funktionieren.
Und dann müssen wir noch Chrome installieren.
Oder Firefox.
Oder meinetwegen, wenn ihr wollt, auch den
neuen Chrome Edge.
Moin spielt gerade.
Was für einen Browser nehmen wir?
Firefox? Chrome?
Chromium? Chrome Edge?
Brave?
Opera? Gaming?
Nein, wir nehmen nicht
Opera Gaming Chat.
Vivaldi. Wir nehmen Vivaldi.
Das finde ich einen guten Vorschlag.
Das finde ich einen guten Vorschlag. Wir nehmen Vivaldi.
Vivaldi taugt.
So, da sind wir.
Links.
Das einzige, wozu man Microsoft Edge braucht.
Vivaldi
Downloaden.
Mach noch einen Snapshot.
Oh, ja. Gut, dass du dran denkst.
Gut, dass du dran denkst.
Ich installiere noch
den Browser und dann mache ich einen Snapshot.
Set. Default.
Hat Vivaldi
den Adblocker defaultmäßig dabei?
Weiß das jemand?
Oder muss ich erst noch uBlock installieren?
Ah, das ist mal ein Next Level.
Auf Bing suchen wir nach Google.
Ok.
uBlock Origin.
Aber wir können einfach den Chrome
den Chrome Block.
Genau.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Ok, ich habe den Knopf getroffen.
Sehr gut.
Nice Aiming Skills.
Sehr schön.
So, und jetzt machen wir einen Snapshot von der VM.
Weil wir müssen das Ding bestimmt noch öfters zurücksetzen.
Dass sowas immer noch unter Windows 10
an Fehlern auftritt, ist komisch.
So ein transparentes Ding.
Ok, also.
GitHub
GitHub Cairo Shell.
Da bin ich mal
gespannt.
Hardware beschleunigen, deaktivieren.
Das kann, ja, das
wird wahrscheinlich da dran liegen.
Hast du mal
ausprobiert,
wie Windows 10 besser läuft?
Mit Hardware Acceleration oder ohne?
Ich würde sagen
pauschal eigentlich mit.
Aber so wirklich sicher bin ich mir
da nicht.
Wäre mit Opera Gaming sicherlich passiert.
Das ist halt auch ein Chrome.
Wahrscheinlich wäre genau das gleiche passiert.
So, Installer.
Prerelease, vor 4 Tagen.
Leute, sind wir mutig?
Wir installieren die aktuelle Beta, oder?
Wenn schon, dann richtig.
Snapshot läuft.
Snapshot läuft, ja.
State saving.
Bleeding Edge or go home.
So sehe ich das auch.
So, jetzt bin ich echt mal
gespannt.
Jetzt bin ich echt mal gespannt.
Ja, ja.
Run.
Wir führen alles aus.
Welcome to Cairo Installer.
Hier machen wir den Kramer zu.
Yes, excellent.
Next.
Agree.
So, was haben wir denn jetzt zur Auswahl?
Run as Startup.
Advanced user only
replace explorer.
Run Cairo instead of Windows Explorer.
No, this has many new features
in Windows.
Wollen wir gleich
das Komplettprogramm machen?
Oder erstmal nur
die Basic Variante installieren?
Go for it.
Okay, volle Pulle.
Bam, install.
Start.
Okay, das ging jetzt relativ easy.
Die Startleiste ist noch da.
Ich sehe sie doch.
Ah, jetzt ist die Startleiste weg.
Aha.
Okay.
So, das ist doch der ganz normale
Windows Explorer.
Ach stimmt, ich vergesse ja immer,
dass der Windows Explorer sowohl
die Shell ist, als auch der Dateimanager.
So.
Es sieht ein bisschen Mac-Style aus.
Es sieht ein bisschen Mac-Style aus,
muss ich sagen.
Ähm.
Wie startet man denn jetzt hier was?
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich
Exit Cairo mache?
Ah, dann startet
Windows wieder. Okay, gut.
Okay, das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Check.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Desktop. What?
What?
Okay, wir starten mal einen Browser.
Sehr schön.
Was ist das?
Oh, das ist ein nice Feature.
Das gefällt mir. Guckt mal.
Man kann, wenn man das Fenster vollbild hat,
den Desktop overlayen
und dann Sachen drin
starten.
Das ist doch cool.
Das gefällt mir echt ganz gut.
Das ist mal ein sinnvolles Feature.
Wer hat schon
solche Verknüpfungen auf dem Desktop?
Ich.
Excellent Verknüpfung
habe ich auf dem Desktop.
Die allerbesten Verknüpfungen überhaupt.
Vor allem habe ich
dreimal CagW in unterschiedlichen
Abwandlungen.
Das ist unglaublich wichtig.
Dass man CagW in 50
Varianten auf dem Desktop hat.
Wie klein kann man eigentlich Windows-Desktops machen?
Ah, so. Top.
Excellent.
Ähm.
Warum kann Windows Transparenz
in Icons, aber ab einer gewissen
Vergrößerung nicht mehr?
Seht ihr das? Ab einer gewissen Vergrößerung
geht die Transparenz in Windows Icons
nicht mehr.
Und dort geht die Transparenz
und beim anderen nicht.
Ist Windows-Kram kaputt?
Bei dem geht sie nicht.
Bei den anderen geht sie dann.
Total kaputt.
Das ist massive.
CagW.
Direkt in Cairo testen.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie ich dort überhaupt
Icons...
Wie komme ich denn jetzt hier überhaupt auf den Desktop?
Ähm.
Okay, man kann schon mal keine Desktop-Icons
verschieben anscheinend.
Desktop.
Was macht das gedönst?
Wow.
Wie?
Was ist das?
Oh, sind das Multiple-Desktops?
Kann das sein?
Ach, das ist der Folder,
den er auf dem Desktop anzeigt.
Ach so. Okay, das ist echt unnötig.
Und jetzt kann man
die Folder, die Ordner hier...
Also man kann tatsächlich mehrere
Desktop-Ordner haben.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht so blöd.
Allerdings hätte ich viel lieber virtuelle
virtuelle
desktops.
Ich hätte viel lieber virtuelle desktops.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Documents, nichts drinne.
Naja, Places, Documents...
Hä?
Ach so, da ist nichts drinne.
Ach, Moment, das ist Datei-Manager
und Browser
in einem.
Das ist ein bisschen wie dieses Start-Menü da von MacOS.
Okay,
da muss man sich tatsächlich
äh
echt dran gewöhnen.
Ich
weiß nicht, ob ich damit klarkomme.
So, was kann das Ding sonst noch?
Desktop-Search.
Lull. Okay, das ist die ganz normale
Windows-Suche.
Ah, okay, das ist der Kram. Also ich kann jetzt hier
zum Beispiel so nach Settings.
Das ist quasi die ganz normale...
Aber...
Man kann
nichts auswählen. Guckt.
Settings. Und da muss ich Maus klicken.
Ich kann nicht hoch und runter gehen. Das wirkt
ein bisschen unfertig, ehrlich gesagt.
Und das ist halt das ganz normale Windows-Zeug.
Okay. Das sind...
im Prinzip Shortcuts zu Ordnern.
Da kann man nicht allzu viel machen.
So, kann das Ding...
Task-View.
Okay, das ist die Übersicht über
meine Tasks.
New Desktop. Ah, wie...
Ah!
Guckt mal!
Es gehen doch Multiple Desktops.
Aber die Task-Leiste ist kaputt.
Die Task-Leiste ist kaputt.
Die Task-Leiste zeigt
weiterhin die Sachen vom ersten Desktop an.
Okay, vielleicht ist das auch Absicht.
Vielleicht ist das auch Absicht.
Aber ich finde das ziemlich
gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Ich meine, guck mal. Ich sehe überhaupt nicht, auf welchem Desktop
ich bin. Wenn ich jetzt da draufklicke,
geht er auf den ersten und da geht er auf den zweiten.
Da wirst du doch verrückt im Kopf.
Da gefällt
mir das standardmäßig schon besser,
dass du hier nur das siehst, was quasi
auf dem jeweiligen Desktop offen ist.
Also, das Ding...
Ansonsten...
Mehr scheint das
nicht zu sein.
Das ist, glaube ich, schon mehr oder weniger alles.
Igitt! Dieses Notification-Fenster.
Dieses Notification-Fenster.
Dieses Notification-Fenster
verwendet keine Sau.
So, man kann lauter und leiser machen.
Ja, da hätte ich mit gerechnet.
Und das sind die normalen Settings.
Okay,
das braucht echt kein Mensch.
Das braucht wirklich
kein Mensch, das Ding.
Das erscheint mir
huge...
huge überflüssig.
Und ich muss euch auch ehrlich sagen,
besser als die normale Oberfläche finde ich es nicht.
Ich meine nur,
weil es von der Leiste einen Ticken
nach Mac aussieht,
ist halt keinerlei der
Funktionalitäten vorhanden.
Ja, vom Style her würde mich das
gar nicht mal großartig stören,
aber von dem Funktionsumfang her
überzeugt mich das nicht wirklich.
Okay, mal gucken, was die sagen, was
sie alles haben.
Wir müssen mal die Features ausprobieren.
Customisable, okay.
Wo ist das Customisable?
Wie kann ich es
customisieren?
Okay, Cairo Settings.
Language, Englisch.
Restart.
Okay.
Wir gucken uns die Settings nochmal an.
About.
Ist das denn...
Das ist definitiv
keine...
Wenn diese Fenster hier aussehen,
ist das keine Native
Windows-Geschichte, oder?
Mal gucken, ob wir rauskriegen,
wie der Kran programmiert ist mit was.
Doch, UWP, oder?
Ist das UWP?
Scheint mir UWP-Zeug zu sein.
Oder, nee, nicht UWP,
wahrscheinlich WPF-Zeugs.
So, was kann man sonst noch einstellen?
Äh, Cairo Settings
gucken wir mal.
Also, das ist auf jeden Fall
Native Windows. So eklig,
wie das hier aussieht. Wahrscheinlich sogar ein Windows...
Alles Windows Forms, oder sowas.
Ähm...
Es ist auf jeden Fall zu klein.
Kann man die Schrift größer machen?
Theme. Flat.
Äh, Moment.
White.
Default.
What?
Ich seh da überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Ah, doch!
Ja, Flat sieht besser aus.
Menübar.
Öh!
Guck mal, die Windows-Leiste.
Die...
Wenn man Windows-Taste drückt, kommt da die Windows-Leiste so rüber.
Nur ohne...
Nur komplett ohne Taskbar.
Okay, so wirklich gut reinpassen tut das Ganze nicht.
Echt, bin ich zu laut?
Bin ich zu...
Nee, ich bin so laut wie immer.
Ich bin so laut wie immer.
Ich hab hier irgendwo auch
meinen Kompressor drin,
dass ich gar nicht zu laut...
Nicht zu laut sein kann.
Debated.
You got...
You got debated.
Was, was ist das?
Schau-Notification-Eigens.
Always.
Warum muss ich eigentlich für alles Cairo restarten?
Ja.
Für alles und für alle unseren Restarten.
Ach, hier oben ist die Notification.
Ach so, jetzt
erkenne ich das.
Ah, yes, excellent, excellent.
So.
Was kann man sonst noch Schönes einstellen?
Blue Behind Menübar.
Ey, Alter, man muss
alles neu starten.
Warum?
Warum muss man alles neu starten?
Äh, ist das jetzt blau?
Ist das jetzt
blauer als vorher?
Irgendwie?
Ich erkenne da keinen Unterschied zu vorher.
Enable Cairo-Menü-Hotkey.
Was?
Win-Shift-Z.
Ach so.
Ach, Blur.
Nicht Blue.
Blur Behind Menübar.
Äh.
Das ist nicht eingeschaltet.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es eine VM ist.
Das sieht man wahrscheinlich in der VM nicht.
Show Menübar on multiple
Monitors.
Ne, geh weg, ich will die neu starten.
Desktop.
Enable Desktop.
Ne, will ich nicht ausschalten.
Icon Size Large.
Man kann die Schriftgröße nicht einstellen.
Das enttäuscht mich ein bisschen.
Weil die Schriftgröße wäre für mich eine wichtige Geschichte.
Weil ich sehe zwar noch gut,
aber ich habe trotzdem gerne die Schriftgröße
ein bisschen größer.
Äh.
Okay, machen wir mal hier groß.
Advanced.
Okay, viel gibt es da nicht.
Also so ultra krass customizable ist das nicht.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich.
Windows 390.
Also das ist Windows, was war das?
Windows 98 im Browser oder so.
Okay, ist ein bisschen größer.
So, schockt mich jetzt nicht großartig.
Das haben wir uns angeguckt.
Das ist das Windows Panel, das kennen wir auch.
Ach guck mal, man kann das alte
Control Panel, das neue aufmachen.
Gut, das kann ich über Startmenü auch.
Das war es.
Mehr gibt es nicht.
Na, das hat mich jetzt. Was ist denn der App Crapper?
What?
Was soll denn das sein?
Procremenu.
Wo ist denn mein Procremenu überhaupt?
Wo ist denn mein Procremenu?
Ach hier, das da.
Ah ja.
Aber angeblich sollten da schon Sachen drin sein.
Okay, adden wir mal, keine Ahnung.
Adden wir mal irgendwas.
Irgendwas dazu.
Den Microsoft Store, den wollte ich schon immer mal geaddet haben.
Continue.
Finish.
Ach so.
Ja, aber das ist,
das ist wirklich
extrem oldschool
die Oberfläche und
also, ich weiß
nicht, also ich bin kein
großer Fan
der,
des Windows Desktops so wirklich, aber
das gefällt
mir nicht.
Windows Transformation Packs, das ist eine gute Frage, ob es den Kram
noch gibt. Früher gab es ja da
viele Sachen, aber ich glaube,
diese Theming Engine ist in Windows gar nicht mehr drinne.
Du könntest auch mal
einen Linux Desktop über WSL und X.
Das muss ich gar nicht probieren, das habe ich schon probiert,
das läuft nicht ordentlich.
Das ist dafür gut, mal was kurz, was zu starten,
wenn man unbedingt was braucht, aber
damit arbeiten kann man nicht.
Also das hat mich jetzt ein bisschen enttäuscht, wirklich
sinnvoll ist da nichts dabei.
Ähm,
und vor allem muss man sagen,
so low das jetzt klingt,
die
Funktionen in Windows selber
sind irgendwie fast
noch schlüssiger als das, was hier
drinne ist. Das gefällt
mir nicht. So.
Weg.
Snapshot.
Restore. Yes.
Zeig noch den Kram, ist zu spät.
Jetzt vorbei.
Was macht ihr da für Dinger im Chat?
So.
Also das war schon mal nichts. Das hat mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Das machen wir weg.
Das war nichts. So, als nächstes
probieren wir den Tiling
Window Manager aus.
Das ist irgendein Auto in
Skript, aber wohl ziemlich beliebt.
Ich meine, das hat 2000 Sterne auf Github.
2000 Sterne auf Github ist ordentlich.
Probieren wir den Kram
mal aus. Ich meine, ihr wisst ja, ich bin großer
Fan von Tiling Window Manager.
Aber unter Windows
habe ich mir da bisher schwer
getan. Installieren wir den Kram
mal. Äh.
Wie installiert man das überhaupt?
Wie?
Wie installiert man das?
Ah. Download Stable Version.
Or Download Current Development Version.
Ok, gut.
Machen wir.
Save as.
Moin, das ist der Source Code.
Ich will, ich will. What?
Ich will doch nicht den Source Code,
aber ich will das einfach ausführen.
Wir sind doch unter Windows.
Äh.
Wir sind doch, wir sind doch unter Windows.
Alter, warum, warum basteln die immer
in ihre, in ihre eigentliche
äh, Background Musik Tracks
irgendwelche Sprachdinger
rein? Geh mal weg.
Oh.
There is no installation process.
Ja, aber wie starte ich es denn?
Ah ja.
You should be able to run it as it is.
Or the main script.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt erstmal Auto-Hotkey
installieren, oder wie? Oh.
Das gefällt mir schon mal nicht.
Ok, also.
Extracten wir das mal.
Ok, runen, runen
kann man das nicht.
You will have a zip file including
executable buggen.exe.
Wo?
Ich hab keine.
Hab ich, stimmt nicht.
Angeblich ist da eine
Exe drin zum Ausführen, ist nicht.
She baited.
Ok, dann downloaden wir mal Stable.
Wir downloaden mal ein Stable. Vielleicht, vielleicht geht das ja auch.
Stable ist
von Mitte 2019 dabei.
Ne.
Ne, das ist der Github-Sourcecode, der
Oh.
MonkaS.
Ah, da ist die Exe. Ok.
Virus.
Man weiß es nie. Aber wir sind in
AVM. Sollte sich in Grenzen halten.
Ok.
Und was kann man damit jetzt machen?
Wie sind denn die Standards?
Das ist wieder ein Readme of Doom.
Wie sind denn
die Standard-Hotkeys?
What? Das verwirrt mich.
What?
Cheatsheet ist gut.
Ok, wir starten
es jetzt einfach mal und gucken.
Oh yeah. Es geht schon los, Leute.
Oh, der meint das mit Tiling. Ernst?
What the fuck?
Oh, der hat die i3-Mappings.
Der hat, Leute, der hat die i3.
Der hat die i3-Tasten-Mappings
drinne.
Oh, Poggers.
Das heißt, ich kann das jetzt nehmen und einfach...
Haha.
Bam.
Na ok, das Tiling ist nicht so ganz,
nicht so ganz
vom Feinsten, was der hier fabriziert.
Hallo?
Oh.
Yes.
Sieht aber etwas
ruckelig aus. Das könnte an der
AVM liegen. Und wie starte ich
jetzt mal? Ach so, hier.
Wo ist mein Vivaldi hin?
What?
Ok, Leute, es funktioniert
nicht richtig.
Es funktioniert nicht richtig.
Guck, ich starte in Explorer
und mein Browser ist weg.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
Oh, jetzt ist er wie...
What the fuck?
What?
Ok, ich mach den Vivaldi mal zu.
Ich glaube, der mag den nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Das ist kaputt.
Broken as fuck.
Kaputt.
Ok, dann probieren wir es noch in Explorer aus.
So, Fullscreen
passt.
Der teilt das nicht, oder?
Ich dachte, man kann das hier anordnen lassen.
Wow.
Was ist das? Null?
Das ist mir zu big brain,
wie das funktioniert.
Alter, das ist mir zu hoch.
Das ist mir echt zu hoch.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Jetzt sind meine Anwendungen weg.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Ne.
Ich meine, der hat bei mir
Pluspunkte instant dadurch gewonnen.
Einmal eins.
Bedeutet, einmal eins
ist alles im Fullscreen?
Null? Was ist denn dieser Fisch?
Ich würde jetzt erwarten,
wenn ich den Explorer starte
und danach, sagen wir mal,
einen Edge,
dann würde ich erwarten, dass der das
teilt.
Und wenn ich noch einen Explorer starte,
würde ich erwarten, dass es links und rechts ist.
Und wenn ich jetzt einen CMD starte, würde ich erwarten...
What?
Was zum Geier passiert da überhaupt?
So, OneNote starten.
Mal gucken.
Ne, das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Das funktioniert nicht richtig. Das ist ja Müll.
Guckt, eigentlich sollte der das jetzt
irgendwie teilen.
Und hier unten drunter guckt noch der
Explorer raus. Der Explorer wurde geteilt,
aber Vivaldi ist Fullscreen.
Ne, das ist Müll.
Das...
Ne.
Wie komme ich denn hier wieder raus?
Wie beendet
man den Spaß denn wieder?
Ich weiß wie.
Snapshot.
So.
Ne, das ist ja enttäuschend bis jetzt.
Das ist ja echt enttäuschend.
Dann gucken wir mal wenigstens, ob
die Open Shell was taugt.
Da bin ich aber sehr
zuversichtlich, dass Open Shell
was taugt, weil
das ist der Nachfolger
von der Classic Shell,
die nicht mal weiterentwickelt wird.
Und die Classic Shell war zu
Windows 8 Zeiten so die Rettung
für alle, die keinen Bock auf Kacheln
hatten. By the way, wir gucken mal kurz
nach, was meine Heizung macht.
Jetzt macht meine Heizung so.
Meine Heizung, Temperatur nimmt
wieder ab.
Der Brenner brennt ab und zu und die Pumpe
pumpt ab und zu.
Das Abgas ist wieder runter gegangen.
Ich muss
das mal einem Heizungsmann zeigen.
Reborn.
Reborn of Classic Shell?
Soll das nicht eher
Rebirth oder so heißen?
Reborn of Classic Shell.
Klingt irgendwie
ein bisschen verkehrt.
Aber wer bin ich
schon mit
meinem krassen
hessischen
Englisch?
Dann downloaden wir das.
Latest Nightly Build.
Gibt es hier vielleicht auch Releases?
Vor 5 Monaten.
Warum ist
das Latest Nightly Build
älter als
das letzte Release?
Ne.
Oder auch nicht.
17 Days ago.
Expires in 5 Monaten.
Keck Wait.
Expires.
Das ist tatsächlich aktuell.
Safen wir einmal das
und laden uns das letzte Release
nochmal runter.
Wir probieren das letzte
echte Release aus.
Next.
Exzellent.
Classic EE.
Ich will eigentlich EE gar nicht
installieren.
Also,
wir installieren einfach alles.
Next.
M.
Yes.
Finish.
Ah.
Guck mal.
Jetzt können wir einstellen was wir haben wollen.
Replace Start Button.
Ah ja.
Das ist doch viel schicker.
Diese komische Shell.
Das sieht hässlich aus.
Der Classic.
Custom. Oh. Leute. Custom Image.
Das müssen wir jetzt machen. Pick Image.
PNG. Also.
Lull.
Wir brauchen das passende Startmenü-Bild.
Ähm.
Transparent.
Und das sein.
Sehr gut.
Das ist das optimale Startmenü-Bild, Leute.
Der Wendler.
Nein, nein, nein. Nicht der Wendler.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Das Bild ist ein bisschen groß.
Nice.
Okay. Wir nehmen mal ein bisschen was kleineres.
Symbol.
Das nehmen wir.
Das ist gut.
Oder das.
Das ist schon fast zu groß.
Save Picture.
Wie? Das passt nicht.
Oh.
Ne, Leute. Es passt nicht.
Es verschiebt sich. Es ist kaputt.
Also Custom Image ist wohl nicht so gut.
Dann nehmen wir
die normale Shell.
Wir können auch Keg W nehmen.
Weil Keg W ist viereckiger.
Quadratischer. Keg W.
Wir gehen einfach mal auf
FFZ Keg W.
So. Das ist doch die opti...
High DPI.
High DPI. Das ist doch die optimale Größe.
Save Picture.
Die optimale Größe
für ein Startbildschirm.
Icon Keg W.
Alter.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Warum ist das so kaputt?
Okay. Dann nehmen wir ein größeres.
Dann nehmen wir das da.
Warum geht mein Rechtsklick nicht?
Was habe ich da überhaupt gerade geöffnet?
Ah.
Was ist das?
Ah. Windows.
Keg W.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das
geöffnet habe.
Dass da Bing default...
Ach so. Ich habe auch Edge auf.
Ich hätte mal besser Vivaldi aufmachen sollen.
Hallo. Seite. Öffnen, please.
Waiting for response.
Das war jetzt...
Die Seite darf ich nicht mehr aufmachen.
Ah, jetzt. Okay. Dann nehmen wir jetzt das Bild.
Save Picture.
Es funktioniert nicht.
Funktioniert nicht.
Kann das sein,
dass der immer
die obere Hälfte nimmt?
Der nimmt die obere Hälfte
für inaktiv.
Der nimmt die Mitte für Hover.
Und der nimmt Klick das untere.
Das heißt, man müsste
sich das extra anfertigen.
Man müsste sich ein Bild anfertigen, was quasi
dreimal das Bild enthält.
Also...
Ja, komm.
Dann nehmen wir...
Wobei das eigentlich ganz lustig ist, oder?
Nee, komm.
Wir nehmen mal die Shell.
Gut. Ähm...
Lies mal eine letzte Nachricht.
Keck W ist deine letzte Nachricht.
Advanced Button Options.
Wow.
What the fuck.
Button Size. Was schreibt man da rein?
20?
Wie kommt man jetzt wieder in die Settings rein?
Oh, nee.
Wie kommt man wieder in die Settings rein?
Classic Shell.
Classic...
Fuck.
Wie kommt man wieder in die Settings?
Ah, hier.
Bleiben wir dabei.
Das ist mir zu advanced.
Okay, also was kann man da sonst noch auswählen?
Select Style of Startmenu.
Windows 7 Style ist das, okay.
Ja.
Das ist eindeutig der Windows 7 Style.
Ähm...
Der ist in der Tat nicht schlecht.
Skin.
Ah. Metallic?
Oh.
Classic?
Windows 2000 lässt grüßen.
Alter.
Metro?
Das ist das halbwegs Aktuelle.
Midnight?
Hm.
Passt irgendwie nicht so richtig
zusammen, ne?
Windows 8?
So blöd sich's anhört, Windows 8
passt von den Farben und den Sachen her
am besten noch in Windows 10.
Windows Aero.
Auch okay.
No Skin.
Äh.
Metro war default, ne?
Okay, was kann man da sonst noch machen?
Windows 7 Classic mit 2?
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Oh, das ist aber
richtig oldschool jetzt.
Das ist jetzt aber mal
hardcore oldschool.
Es ist aber schön schnell, muss man sagen.
Es fühlt sich wirklich schön schnell an.
Hier tracken, droppen kann man das nicht.
Das ist tatsächlich gar nicht mal so
gar nicht mal so blöd.
Ah, es fühlt sich, es fühlt sich doch ein bisschen
zäh an. Aber
so schlecht ist das gar nicht mal.
Allerdings, das fühlt sich
schon ein bisschen zäh an.
Dann machen wir mal lieber Windows 7 Style.
Der fühlt sich
deutlich flüssiger an.
Der ruckelt, der ruckelt.
Also, beste was wir machen können ist Windows 7 Style.
Der Rest ruckelt rum.
Das hier ruckelt nicht.
Ist das weiterhin die schlechte Suche?
Ich denke mal,
das ist gar keine Suche,
sondern nur intern
im Startmenü.
Lull.
Oh, doch!
Files.
Das wird die Windows-Suche
sein, denke ich.
Ich denke, das wird die Windows-Suche sein.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie eine eigene Desktop-Suche
irgendwie implementiert haben.
Okay, man kann wieder ordentlich tracken, droppen.
Ich finde das gar nicht mal schlecht.
Ich finde das wirklich
nicht übel, was sie hier gebastelt haben.
Ah, das Windows-Startmenü
kann man auch aufmachen.
Falls man irgendwas nicht findet.
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel.
So, und der beste Skin war
tatsächlich, finde ich,
bisher Windows 8.
Allerdings nervt mich das Weiße.
Das finde ich so schon besser.
So, was kann man da sonst noch alles einstellen?
Zeigt mal her, was haben wir da für Optionen?
Meins sieht so aus.
Zeigt mal her.
Oh, Darksteam. Beste.
So schaut es bei ihm aus.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nett.
Erstmal das ganze Jetbrains Zeugs am Start.
Large Font, genau.
Das ist wichtig.
Das brauchen wir, Large Font.
Ist das jetzt Durchsichtiger?
Ich glaube, das Durchsichtige funktioniert
bei mir nicht.
Na doch, ein bisschen.
Das Durchsichtige wird in der VM nicht ordentlich funktionieren.
Ah!
Ja, ohne...
Ohne Frames ist besser.
Mit Frames sieht es kacke aus.
Das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so übel.
So, was kann man sonst noch alles einstellen?
Einfach mal
im Schnellverfahren gucken.
Controls. Okay, ganz viel Gedöns.
Noch mehr Gedöns.
Das muss man sich...
Das werde ich mir jetzt nicht alles im Detail angucken.
Das ist ja mega Resident Sleeper.
Aber ich finde schon mal gut, dass es sehr customizable ist.
Aha.
User Picture.
Ich habe kein User Picture eingestellt.
Weil ich ein
Local Account bin.
Und bei Microsoft darf man bei einem Local Account wahrscheinlich kein Bild mehr hinterlegen.
Search Box.
Select by default.
Access with Tab.
Oh, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Oh, das ist cool.
Dass man sogar sagen könnte, man möchte das nicht haben.
Das finde ich ist eine gute Option.
Menu Delay.
Wo hast du denn das gesehen?
Wenn man hier drüber geht,
wie lange es dauert, bis das Untermenü aufgeht.
Das ist aber eigentlich ganz gut, dass es ein gewisses
Delay hat, weil ansonsten ist es ja
permanent am rumflickern,
wenn man da drüber geht.
Das finde ich
ganz gut.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes?
Main Menu, Search Box,
Menu Look,
Skin, Language,
Sounds,
Context Menü,
Taskbar,
Customize Taskbar?
What?
Ah ja gut, das kann ich für das auch machen.
Ich muss euch sagen,
mir gefällt das.
Es hat irgendwie was.
Ich habe mich jetzt allerdings
Net1
Kann man jetzt auch sagen,
Explorer öffnen?
Oh, cool.
Net1, das ist so eine typische Microsoft
Benahmung, weil es Net schon gab.
Gibt es ein Net1.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
so cool das sein mag an
Features und sowas,
das normale Windows 10
Startmenü tut es
irgendwie auch.
Wobei ich finde es
deutlich besser als das andere, was wir da
ausprobiert haben.
Ich meine, es ist nur ein Startmenü, aber dafür ist es halt ein ordentliches.
Multi F
101, zwei Monate.
Dankeschön.
So,
die haben noch ein bisschen mehr dabei.
Die haben angeblich noch extra Explorer.
Wir müssen uns den Internet Explorer angucken.
Der hat angeblich auch irgendwas eingebaut.
Okay,
was auch immer.
Man hat jetzt komische Icons hier oben im Explorer.
Was ist das?
Follow Options.
Wozu braucht man das denn?
Okay, das ist ziemlich unsinnig.
Okay, jetzt haben wir den Classic Explorer.
Ich sehe überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Seht ihr den Unterschied?
Aber wir sind auch unter Windows.
Da darf man nicht vergessen, dass wir vielleicht neu starten müssen.
Wir müssen bestimmt neu starten,
dafür, dass das funktioniert.
Gucken wir mal.
Microsoft Bob.
So, mal schauen,
ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Okay, das startet sich automatisch.
Das ist gut und schlecht zugleich.
Wenn es einem gefällt, ist es gut.
Wenn man es wieder wegkriegen will, ist es schlecht.
Hä?
Leute, ich sehe da überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Wenn man unter Linux dieselben Spiele spielen könnte wie unter Windows,
wenn man unter Linux dieselben Spiele spielen könnte wie unter Windows,
wäre es nur unter Linux unterwegs.
Ja, ich auch.
Also sollte es wirklich die Möglichkeit geben,
irgendwann mal
die Sachen, die ich unter Windows mache,
auch unter Linux machen zu können,
dann würde ich sofort nur noch Linux verwenden.
Aber, gibt es halt nicht.
Okay, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht wirklich.
E-Mail Selected Items.
Das ist aber gefährlich,
weil man das aus versehen macht.
Okay, die
Explorer Extensions
sind jetzt nicht so huge.
Die Explorer Extensions
brauche ich jetzt nicht wirklich.
Kann man die Explorer
Sachen wieder deinstallieren?
Classic
E-E-Settings
Okay, dann gucken wir mal, ob wir das
entfernen können.
Classic Shell
Uninstall
Wir können es bloß uninstallen.
Müssen wir das komplett löschen,
dass man die anderen Sachen wegmachen kann?
Jetzt ist wieder das normale Windows da.
Also das Menü an sich
fand ich echt nicht schlecht.
Wir installieren jetzt nochmal
die Testversion.
Also
Classic E-E wollen wir nicht.
Classic Explorer
wollen wir auch nicht.
Guck mal, da hat sich die Settings
gemerkt. Das ist doch schonmal ganz schön.
Ich kann Copy-Paste,
das ist das wichtigste.
Recent Items
und mein Explorer sieht wieder normal aus.
Sehr gut.
Also von allen Sachen, die wir heute
getestet haben
ist...
Von allen Sachen, die wir heute getestet haben
muss man testen, wie schnell das reagiert.
Nicht schnell genug teilweise.
Ich drücke den Shortcut für den Explorer,
obwohl ich eigentlich das hier machen will.
Unter Windows kein Problem.
Ah doch.
Ich bin generell zu schnell, gerade beim drücken.
Ich find's gut, also das ist echt gut.
Search Internet for 1. Oh ne, wir suchen nicht nach 1.
Man weiß, was man unter 1 alles findet.
Das ist doch nice.
Also das finde ich ist ein schönes Ding.
Und schon ne cute Oberfläche gefunden.
Ne, alles Müll.
Ja, das Anti-Cheat ist tatsächlich ein Problem.
Aber auch unter Proton hast du noch einige Probleme
mit den Spielen an sich.
Du hast umgedreht.
Du hast eigentlich eher Probleme
und einige Sachen, die ganz
zufriedenstellend funktionieren.
Power Toys, ne die neuen Power Toys
habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Also die anderen 2 Sachen habe ich jetzt echt enttäuscht.
Das Ding finde ich ganz nice,
wenn man es braucht, aber wirklich
wirklich sinnvoll.
Ich meine,
ein paar von euch verwenden das doch.
Warum verwendet ihr lieber
die Classic Shell
als das Windows
Standard Startmenü?
Der Carlson, 6 Monate in Folge.
Big Brain Sub.
Samus Climber
Prime
Voll verklickt.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Plus 1.
Gewohnheit, okay.
Es sieht halt aus
wie das Windows 10
Startmenü.
Wie das Windows 7 Startmenü.
Es verhält sich auch ähnlich wie das Windows Startmenü.
Es ruckelt auch wie das Windows 10
Startmenü.
Ist halt edgy, wenn man nichts Standard verwendet.
Wenn du nichts Standard verwenden willst,
wie wäre es mit einer Linux-VM?
Wie wäre es mit einer Linux-VM,
wenn du was richtig
ausgefallenes verwenden willst?
Wir haben heute richtig viel
ausprobiert. Guck mal, nur 1 Stunde
40 on und schon
alles durchprobiert, was ich probieren wollte.
Okay, ich würde sagen, wir gehen jetzt auf
Snapshot, Restore
und löschen den Kram
wieder alles. Gut,
also von dem ganzen Zeug, was wir heute ausprobiert
haben, ist eindeutig die
Classic Shell, also die Open, wie heißt das Ding?
Open Windows Shell oder so.
Open Shell Menü.
Eindeutig das Beste gewesen.
Den anderen Kram kann man voll vergessen.
Ja, Pepega-Spam
ist angesagt.
Also das andere Zeug, also
das war, da hatte ich,
da habe ich mir ein bisschen was von versprochen, nachdem ich
das hier gesehen habe, aber
es war
irgendwie belanglos, ja, also
pfff
weiß nicht,
wovor man das verwenden soll.
Die Konzepte waren auch nicht so ganz
schlüssig, an vielen Stellen hat es auch nicht
gut funktioniert, wie zum Beispiel mit den
virtuellen Desktops, die gar nicht richtig funktioniert
haben.
Ne, das war nix.
Das hier ist gut gedacht,
backt aber übelst rum
und das einzige, was funktioniert hat
und das macht, was wir ausprobiert haben, ist tatsächlich das da
und das ist auch wohl ganz gut.
Hast du schon mal
Vox ausprobiert, bist du ähnlich wie Rofi?
Ne, habe ich noch nichts ausprobiert.
Github, was ist das? Vox.
Der Vox Launcher
for Windows. Oh!
What?
15,7K?
Boah!
Das probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus.
What the fuck?
15,7K ist
massive.
Was für eine Distro würdest du als
VM für einen Linux-Anfänger empfehlen?
Also von denen, die wir
hier im Stream getestet haben,
muss ich sagen, hat mir
elementary und
das Deep in China Linux
am besten gefallen. Allerdings,
wenn du mit was
normalem anfangen willst,
was einfach nur gehen soll
und
du auch
viel Support dazu findest,
dann ist, hat glaube ich gerade einer im Chat
auch schon geschrieben, dann ist Linux Mint
nicht verkehrt. Allerdings
wenn du es in der VM betreiben willst,
kannst du
ich überlege gerade, welcher
es war, die haben zwei Desktops.
Die haben, genau,
wenn du es in der VM benutzen
willst, entweder
XFCE oder Mate Desktop.
Cinnamon ist in der VM nicht so gut.
Oder war es umgedreht?
War Mate nicht so gut
und Cinnamon gut in der VM?
XFCE ist auf jeden Fall das leichtgewichtigste
davon.
Zorin hatten wir ausprobiert.
Ich hatte irgendwelche
Schmerzen mit Zorin.
Irgendwas hat mir an Zorin
nicht gefallen.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr was.
Warum nicht einfach Ubuntu?
Kann man auch machen. Allerdings ist die
Ubuntu Standard Installation in der VM
nicht richtig lauffähig.
Dadurch, dass die 3D Beschleunigung
brauchen für Desktop.
Aber damit
kann man nichts falsch machen.
Ich persönlich schwöre ja auf
E3 WM.
Da hat man zwar keine
fancy Effekte,
aber es ist saumäßig schnell,
weil man sich dran gewöhnt hat.
So, also was wollten wir jetzt nochmal
ausprobieren? Den VOX Launcher.
Oh, kann man nicht copy-pasten
ordentlich?
Doch.
Hallo, ich habe Enter gedrückt.
What the fuck?
Was war das gerade?
E3 war so ein Tiling
Ding, ja. Das ist aber
gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Also wenn du jetzt erst anfängst
mit ähm
Wenn du jetzt erst damit anfängst
Hallo, kann die Seite sich mal öffnen?
What?
Ach die Seite gibt es nicht.
Na das ist ja toll.
Ist das Projekt vielleicht abandoned oder so?
Ach stimmt ja, das kann sein.
Ok, also Download.
Wo ist es?
Save.
Bam.
Was kann ich jetzt machen?
Was? 2018?
Hä?
Und jetzt?
Ah, das ist so ein Launcher.
Also da kann ich jetzt sowas machen wie 2 plus 2.
Oh!
Big Brain, das ist 4.
Quick Muffs.
Release 2018?
Ne.
MINT? MINT hat aktuelles
MINT ist von
äh
kam das raus?
Ja, Ende 2019.
Ach der Vox Launcher.
Stimmt.
Von 2018.
Seitdem gab es nichts neues mehr.
Ja das ist Fail.
Dead.
Komplett
Und die Seite ist auch Dead.
Dabei hat das Projekt
schon einiges Hype gehabt mit
15,7 Stern.
Äh 7000 Stern.
15.700 Stern.
So, wenn man das startet.
Der startet ewig lange, ne?
Ach ne.
Hä?
Jetzt ist er kaputt, Leute. Wir haben ihn zerstört.
Eben ging er noch.
Jetzt ist er weg.
Ah, da ist er. Settings.
Äh, kann man da
Hotkey einstellen mit was er launcht?
Hotkey?
Was ist der Hotkey dafür?
Alt Space.
Ah.
Okay.
Wow. Okay, hübsch.
Hübsch ist was anderes.
Ich muss mir mal angucken in was das programmiert ist.
Ich hoffe nicht Elektron oder
irgendwie sowas.
Man weiß ja heutzutage nie.
Oh ne
WPF anscheinend oder UWP.
Aber ich finde ganz ehrlich
diese Input Box
die sieht übelst nach einem Input Feld aus dem Browser aus.
Oder? Findet ihr nicht auch?
Das sieht übelst nach einem Browser Input Feld aus.
Okay. Also.
Was kann man da jetzt machen zum Beispiel schönes?
Sagen wir mal Vivaldi starten.
Aber wo ist der Vorteil davon?
Gegenüber
Gegenüber einem Startmenü?
Ich meine da kann
Okay, da kann er wahrscheinlich noch mehr.
Zeig mal mal.
Was ist da standardmäßig für Plugins drinne?
Was kann
da standardmäßig alles?
Teamania. Moin.
Der Calculator.
2 plus 2
ist 4.
Minus 1.
Das können wir hier drinnen machen.
2 plus 2
minus 1.
Jawoll.
Colors.
Okay. Das heißt ich kann erst mal sagen
Hex F F F F
Okay das ist ganz nice.
Wäre cool wenn es so einen Color Picker hätte.
Control Panel.
Everything.
Was?
Search on disk files using everything.
Everything ist bestimmt ein eigenes Search Tool oder?
Das kenne ich nicht.
Ah hier.
Das ist ein eigenes Search Tool für Windows.
Kein Wunder dass es nicht funktioniert.
Folder suchen. Plugins. Programme.
Shell Kommandos. System Kommandos.
Url.
Das heißt ich kann auch sowas hier machen.
Wie google.de
Ok.
Das ist tatsächlich.
Das ist wirklich recht praktisch.
Warum gibt es da keine neue Version von?
2008. Das ist doch kacke.
Websearch.
Also kann ich auch sowas machen wie hier.
Wupp Wupp Wupp Wupp.
Ne da kann ich nicht. Ich muss machen G.
Ok das ist auch ok.
Doch das habe ich. Klar habe ich das mal ausprobiert.
Das habe ich schon vor Jahren mal ausprobiert.
Jetzt mit der Suche. Jetzt wo ich das sehe mit der Suche.
Jetzt fällt mir das wieder ein.
Was mich genau.
Da hat mich damals schon genervt dass man nicht irgendwas eintippen kann.
Und dann Enter drücken kann und dann sucht er Google.
Jaja.
Hat das Auto Complete?
Hat kein Auto Complete.
Ähm.
Hat das.
Gibt es ein offizielles Plugin Repo?
Äh.
Das ist dead.
Das ist richtig dead.
Probieren wir es mal aus.
Everything Void Tools.
Ist ja noch vor M.
Kann ja nicht viel schief gehen.
Also die Seite ist
dead.
Du kannst Suggestions anmachen.
Save Knopf gibt es nicht.
Ok das heißt wenn ich jetzt danach suche.
Nach Max.
Haha she baited.
Oder hat er das jetzt nicht übernommen.
Ne.
Die Suggestions
kommen wahrscheinlich erst wenn ich mache
Geh.
Geh. Hallo.
Ah yes.
Geh.
Ah ja guck mal da ist er.
Ok.
Download Installer.
Dann lassen wir mal unsere Platte indizieren.
Gucken was das macht.
Wäre es nicht schön wenn es in Windows einen offiziellen
Paketmanager gebe?
Raffunkeldunkel.
Ja und ich äh.
Liebe natürlich den Chat.
Was sonst?
Jetzt gleich erstmal den Scam Train auf 100% prügeln.
Benutzt du ähm.
Was nutzt du als Stromversorgung
für den ESP2866?
Naja.
Wenn ein USB Stecker dran ist.
Das Ding braucht ja nichts.
Ich habe einige Steckdosen.
Die haben direkt USB mit dabei.
Ja aber das ist nichts offizielles.
Ich meine sowas richtig offizielles.
Paketmanager.
Und Microsoft hat zu überreden alles an Windows
Software zu hosten. Ja.
Na klar.
Ey wenn das irgendwie
äh ein Team
aus äh
Freiwilligen machen kann.
Dann kann das Microsoft auch machen.
Ich meine die müssten es nicht unbedingt hosten.
Aber die müssten das Ding verifizieren.
Den ESP autark ohne Steckdose.
Äh mit Batterie.
Äh mit Batterie ist die Herausforderung.
Du brauchst erstmal das richtige Board.
Dafür.
Also was ich dir empfehlen kann als
ESP32.
Beim ESP2866 bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Wenn du es wirklich an der Batterie betreiben willst.
Ist der hier gut.
Der ist halt ein bisschen teurer.
Ähm so gut wie kein Stromverbrauch
wenn er im Deep Sleep ist.
Das Board.
Das hat auch gleich einen Batterie Connector dran.
Und dann nimmst du so ne
Dann nimmst du
so ne kleine Batterie. Sowas da.
Und stöpselst äh
Sowas da nimmst du.
Da habe ich
zwei Stück von. Von den Fire Beetle 32.
Normale
ESP32 Boards
verbrauchen zu viel. Weil die haben ja ein USB
dran. Und die Dinger
sind so noob äh noob
stylig gemacht vom Hersteller.
Dass die auch im Batteriebetrieb
dann den den USB
Anschluss im Strom versorgen und sowas.
Die brauchen zu viel. Der Fire Beetle
braucht wirklich nichts. Also so gut wie
nichts. Der braucht glaub ich
zehn äh zehn Mikroampere
oder so im Deep Sleep.
Raffunkeldunkel
Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Nice.
So. Als erstes erleben wir das mal. Ich hab
Siehst du mal. Ich probier immer richtig viel Windows Gedöns
aus. Was ich sonst ja natürlich nicht mache.
Weil mich
zumindest das Holz am Arsch vorbei geht.
Was man so unter Windows in der Richtung machen kann.
Okay.
Immer installen.
Yes.
Excellent.
Run.
Und jetzt
indiziert er so vor sich hin
Search. Na gut auf der Festplatte
ist ja nicht viel drauf.
Das ist sowas wie Locate für Linux.
Das
erscheint. Das sieht für mich aus wie ein bisschen
bisschen wie was
wie Locate im Endeffekt.
Einfach ein kleiner Index
über die. Weil man kann auch keinen Inhalt
suchen. Einfach
einen Index über die Dateinamen.
Richtig interessant wird's
ja bei Indizierung vom Inhalt her.
Kann er auch Inhalt
suchen?
Kann er auch Inhalt suchen?
Nee oder?
Bloop.
Inhalt kann er nicht suchen.
Den Inhalt kann er nicht indizieren.
Inhalt
Inhalt indiziert er nicht.
Okay.
Das heißt jetzt kann ich aber
Files da drüber suchen.
Bloop. Ah.
Okay das ist tatsächlich ganz cool.
Das gefällt mir gut.
Microsoft wollte doch mal
vor 10 Jahren
Dings. Next.
Next Get oder so sollte das heißen.
Das haben sie nicht gebacken gekriegt.
Da habe ich so ein Video damals drüber gemacht.
Wo gibt es denn aktuelle
Builds von diesem anderen Tool hier?
Weil ich meine
2000, 2008
ist halt schon
Bild
gibt es halt. Ist halt ein bisschen alt oder?
Ich meine will der
nicht mal ein neues Release machen?
2008.
Die ist sehr alt. Das ist ein Jahr.
Ein Jahr
hinten dran.
Ob die Leute sich schon beschweren.
New Release.
Hat auch einer gepostet.
Okay irgendein Typ
kompiliert das selbst.
Aber das ist jetzt halt wieder auch so was
inoffizielles.
Das scheint mir so ein Ding zu sein
was so halb supported ist.
2018 meine ich.
Ja ihr wisst doch, dass ich manchmal komische
wenn ich mich nicht darauf konzentriere
was ich sage, dann kann es sein, dass
ich manchmal komisches Zeug erzähle.
An sich
finde ich das von den Funktionen her aber ziemlich
nice. Muss ich mal sagen.
Das hat was.
Der riesen Vorteil zum Startmenü
zum Launchen von Anwendungen
erschließt sich mir jetzt noch nicht.
Aber das kommt wahrscheinlich erst dann
wenn man die
Details verwendet. Die Sache ist die
ich glaube das Produkt ist ziemlich
tot, weil
die offizielle Seite geht halt nicht mehr.
Und in der Regel ist wenn die offizielle Seite
von einem Produkt tot ist, ist
meistens kein gutes Zeichen.
Gibt es da eine Übersicht mit Plugins?
Okay da gibt es wirklich 30 Milliarden Sachen.
Eine Putty Session
oh das ist für alle Windows Leute natürlich super.
Wie Rofi für Windows.
Ja aber Rofi gefällt mir viel besser.
Ich benutze ja Rofi auch nur als Launcher.
Die ganzen Zusatzfunktionen wie Fenster suchen
ich habe ja keine Fenster und irgendwelche
Special Sachen mache ich nicht.
Es gibt dazu
wie heißt die Rofi Alternative
nochmal? Da gab es doch
letztens was habe ich gesehen.
Da gab es doch letztens was.
U-Launcher? Ne, ne, ne.
Rofi Clipboard, da habe ich mir was eigenes gestrickt.
Ich wusste gar nicht
dass es da jetzt was offizielles gibt.
Wayland.
Wer ist so lebensmüde und verwendet
Wayland?
Rofi.
Komische Uhr.
Green Clip.
Was war das hier?
Highskill. Warte.
Highskill. Monkeys.
Ich finde das Ding
aber wirklich doch, doch ich muss sagen
das ist ganz nützlich.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz, ganz praktisch.
Vor allem mit dem Indizieren von
ähm
Wo kommt das her?
Oh das ist irgendwas
von Windows. Okay.
Vor allem mit dem
integrieren von der Windows-Suche
finde ich das wirklich ganz praktisch.
Die Frage der Fragen, die wir natürlich
klären müssen ist, ist das in meinem
Paketmanager drinne?
Vox.
Ja.
Suchen please.
Okay, ist drinne.
Das finde ich gut.
War das auch das aktuelle Release?
Oder ist das schon was neueres
was die drinne haben?
Eins, drei, fünf, sieben, acht.
Oh ne, das ist ja noch älter.
Das ist ja noch älter
was da im Repo drinne ist.
Da sieht man halt wieder
was das Problem ist, dass Windows
kein Dateimanager hat.
Das ist von Februar 2018.
Da sieht man halt wieder was das Problem ist, dass Windows
kein Dateimanager hat.
Natürlich kann das von der Community
gemacht werden, beziehungsweise
von irgendwelchen ähm
einzelnen Kriegern gemacht werden, aber
unterm Strich
ist halt die Pflege der Sachen
hinüber, sobald die Leute
keinen Bock mehr haben.
Was war das? Latest Stable?
Ach tatsächlich, hab nix gesagt.
Aber trotzdem, stimmt ja, was ich gesagt hab.
Ähm.
Ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Deswegen, es wär
es wär echt was
Nices für Windows, wenn die
mal es schaffen würden, einen offiziellen Paketmanager
bereitzustellen und der halt
und nicht der Windows Store, Alter. Niemand
vertreibt seine Software, der noch mal Sinn ist über den Windows Store.
Ähm.
Äh.
Kenmore weiß jetzt nicht genau, was das spezif-
Also das einzige, was ich bisher
mal gemacht habe, so mit UI
Automatisierung, ist ähm
Puppeteer, diese Chrome Fernsteuerung.
Kannst du
kurz mal Git erklären?
Kurz äh, kurz geht das nicht.
Okay, und dann wollte ich auch gucken, ob dieses Search
drinne ist.
Nee, Everything hieß das. Hab ich verguckt.
Ja, Tools war der Hersteller, oder?
Everything hieß das. Auf Search.
Ah!
Okay.
Also die Kombination, muss ich sagen, finde
ich ganz brauchbar.
Die Kombination finde ich wirklich ganz nice.
Ah, Paint, bam.
Keiner startet da drüber. Paint, aber
ja. Äh, dass
man direkt ne Google-Suche machen kann. Oh, what the
fuck. Direkt ne Google-Suche
machen kann, finde ich sehr gut.
Ähm, dass die Suggestions
macht, finde ich nice.
Wenn du sowas für Linux, ich brauch das
nicht für Linux. Ich hab
ich hab alles für Linux in der Richtung
schon. Ich brauch eher was ordentliches
für Windows.
Aber U-Launcher wird überhaupt
nicht mal weiterverwickelt, oder?
Oder ist das jetzt was?
Ach nee, das ist was Neues.
U-Launcher.
Das hab ich noch, das hab ich noch nicht
ausprobiert. Aber ich muss
ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich bin da, äh
ich starte da drüber eh nur Programme.
Die ganzen fancy Sachen mach ich da drüber gar nicht.
Max, Mac
OS oder Windows, was findest du besser?
Boah, in welchem Bereich?
In welchem Bereich? Ähm,
letztendlich
müsste ich
so, wenn ich spontan antworten müsste,
würde ich sagen, ganz klar Mac.
Weil, ähm, du zumindest ne ganz
gute Chance hast, ne ordentliche
Programmier- äh, Umgebung
und ne Unix-artige, Linux-artige
Umgebung unter Mac hinzubekommen.
Ähm,
du hast ne ordentliche Shell, du hast ne ordentliches Terminal.
iTerm 2 finde ich
fast noch ein Ticken besser, als die Sachen,
die es unter Linux gibt. Ähm,
und
aber unterm
Strich kommt's ja drauf an,
was man
für Anwendungen braucht.
Und da bist du halt
unter Windows
von der Auswahl her
immer noch besser aufgehoben.
Es gibt die ein oder andere, es gibt schöne
Anwendungen für Mac, die ist nicht
unter, unter Windows gibt.
Zum Beispiel hätte
ich mir vor Jahren mal gerne ne
Omni-Graphical-Version für Windows gewünscht.
Das ist so ein Visio.
Das war noch die Zeit, als ich sowas wie, äh,
sowas wie Visio verwendet habe.
Und das ist halt unter,
unter, äh, Mac ist das viel, viel
angenehmer als diese Windows, als dieser Windows
Visio-Geschiss
da.
Air-Freezing mit der Instanz, äh, Instant
Indizierung auf Linux.
Hab ich noch nie geguckt, was es gibt.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Also integriert, integriert
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich nix.
Aber Rofi ist ziemlich
erweiter, erweiter, erweiterbar.
Also wenn man ein ordentliches Index-Tool unter
Linux hat, kann man das, denk ich, auch
ganz gut integrieren.
Welchen Stuhl benutzt du fürs 10 Plus Stunden?
Den hier. Den hier.
Der da. Bester Stuhl,
Leute. Der beste Stuhl,
den ich, äh, je benutzt hab.
Ich krieg dafür kein Geld.
Hast du dir schon mal
Schokolade angeguckt?
Ja, hab ich. Vor ner ganzen Weile.
Ähm, in letzter Zeit nicht
mehr. Ähm, ich verwende
für, ich verwende eigentlich nur noch
Scoop für meine Entwicklungssachen.
Ähm, das ist
allerdings nicht systemweit, sondern
nur lokal bei mir
im Benutzerverzeichnis. Und das reicht mir.
Was mir bei Schokolade
das letzte Mal überhaupt nicht gefallen hat, war
die Oberfläche. Und auch dieses
im Hintergrund rumgewurstete
Ding mit den PowerShell-Skripten,
die teilweise nicht richtig gelaufen sind.
Da muss man
halt sagen, da ist Linux mit nem ordentlichen
Paketmanager wirklich meilenweit vorne.
Und die Premium-Lösung ist natürlich
ein ordentlicher Paketmanager plus User-Repos,
wie das unter Arch Linux ist.
Das finde ich ist immer noch top. Ähm,
genau.
Und da muss man halt gucken,
da muss man halt gucken,
äh, dass man den für nen ordentlichen Preis
kriegt.
800 Euro ist definitiv, äh,
definitiv zu viel.
Ähm, wenn man ein bisschen rumguckt
und ein bisschen, ein bisschen nachschaut,
kriegt man den schon ne ganze Ecke günstiger.
Also, ich könnte mir durchaus
vorstellen, dass man die Möglichkeit hat,
den Stuhl für
ne ganze Ecke unter 1000 Euro zu
finden, wenn man ein bisschen schaut.
Das ist übrigens genau die Config,
die ich bei mir stehen hab hier.
Beim Büro Götz.
Äh, das ist genau die Config,
die ich hier bei mir stehen hab.
Warum kann man das Bild nicht groß machen?
Hier ist das Bild doch auch viel größer.
Lul, keck, weh.
Das ist ja so ein komischer Shop,
der nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ähm, das ist genau die Config,
die ich hier auch bei mir stehen hab.
Mit dieser Kopfstütze.
Die ist mir allerdings nicht, nicht
groß genug, die,
die Kopfstütze.
Ähm, ich hab da noch so ein extra,
noch so ein kleines Kissen dran,
mit so nem, mit so nem Gummiband
oben, was extra für so Stühle gemacht ist.
Ähm,
aber der Stuhl ist halt echt
gut. Wie gesagt,
ihr erinnert euch ja noch dran, im letzten
Stream, wo ich das mit der Bluetooth Waage ausprobiert
hab. Das heißt, ihr wisst, was
ich wiege.
Ähm, ist übrigens wieder ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Noch weniger, als beim letzten, beim letzten Stream.
Äh, seid froh, dass ich nicht,
dass ich den Stream nicht an Weihnachten gemacht hab, ey.
Ähm,
und,
also wenn ich mich hier,
wenn ich mich hier draufschmeiße,
auf den Stuhl hier, BÄM,
der federt, aber
da wackelt nix, macht
nix, also das ist, der ist auch
Kokona-tauglich, ja.
Hast du keinen Max-400-Euro-Stuhl?
Ich hatte, ich hatte davor
nen DX Racer-Stuhl,
der war ne ganze Ecke günstiger als
400 Euro, aber der war kacke.
Ich hatte den Auswahl
danach, kauf ich mir nochmal so ein halbes Ding,
oder kauf ich mir den, und ich
hab mir den gekauft.
Das heißt, kriegt man auch einen Hermann Miller Premium
in Office-Stühlen, was ergonomisch ist.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die besser sind,
als die. Das ist der beste Stuhl, auf dem
ich je gesessen hab.
Und das ist jetzt wirklich keine
Übertreibung, ich krieg auch kein Geld von denen.
Ich hab viele
Stühle ausprobiert, weil
wir hatten auf der Arbeit mal ne,
ne richtige Probierwelle
an Stühlen, äh, was die
kaufen sollen. Ich hab massig Stühle ausprobiert,
und nichts ging über diesen Stuhl.
Also empfohlen.
Es kann sein, dass das auch gute Stühle sind,
aber der ist für mich der absolut beste Stuhl.
Gibt für mich nichts besseres.
Zeigt mir mal einen, der empfohlen wird auf Reddit.
Ich will das mal vergleichen.
Hast du den auch in der Arbeit?
Ja, den haben wir auch auf der Arbeit.
Das heißt, ich sitze im Prinzip
am Tag, ich sitze den gesamten
Tag in diesem Stuhl.
Ich sitze auf der Arbeit in diesem Stuhl, und ich sitze daheim
in diesem Stuhl.
Und ich muss schon überzeugt sein,
von nem Stuhl, dass ich 1000 Euro für den Stuhl
ausgebe.
Ja, und DX Racer ist Crap.
Der DX Racer Stuhl ist jetzt
no Witz auseinandergebrochen.
Am Rahmen
auseinandergebrochen, alter.
Was mit dem Ding, äh,
und das nach knapp nem Jahr.
Was hältst du von
Back Force 1? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Was, was zum Beispiel ist
Back Force 1?
Hört sich nach Gaming RGB Stuhl an.
Pro Equipment
für echt, nein.
Das sieht nicht wie was aus, was ich mir kaufen würde.
Außerdem lag
die Webseite extrem.
Ne, ne.
Da
hab ich, hab ich
instinktive Abneigung, Abneigung dagegen,
wenn ich das sehe.
Ich kann euch nicht genau sagen, was, aber
da hab ich instant Abneigung
dagegen.
Wo hast du den Seedos Stuhl gekauft? Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Das ist zu lang her.
Medi-Critical.
Sag mir mal einen, nach dem ich gucken soll.
Sag mir mal einen Stuhl, nach dem ich gucken soll.
Aeron, okay.
Hier ist die
Miller.
Aeron. Okay, da ist auch
Wat?
The fuck?
Das hat überhaupt kein
richtigen Polster, kein richtiges Polster am Rücken.
Das sieht nicht bequem aus.
Jetzt ernsthaft,
also ich will, ich will es nicht jetzt
auf Teufel komm raus niedermachen.
Aber du hast ja da einfach nur ein paar
Stofflappen am Rücken.
Den Backforce hat ja Inscorp21
und schlägt den immer am Anfang seiner Videos vor.
Denn Nico wird die Dinger am Anfang
seines Videos vorschlagen, weil er dafür Geld kriegt.
Und weil der Nico wahrscheinlich
auch nicht allzu viele Stühle ausprobiert hat.
Dafür bist du im Sommer nicht am schwitzen.
Ach gut, bin ich auch so nicht.
Bei meiner Klimaanlage.
Belegtes Brot abonniert Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön, huge.
Embody haben wir da noch.
Also ich kann es jetzt letztendlich nicht
beurteilen, weil ich habe die Dinger noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber ich finde nicht,
dass die Dinger
bequem am Rücken aussehen.
Ne, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht irgendwie.
Da bleibe ich lieber bei meinem 24-7 Stuhl.
Also gut,
ich bleibe da eh dabei, weil einen 1.000 Euro Stuhl
schmeißt man nicht einfach weg.
Und das Ding
kann ich auch nichts zu sagen.
Wie gesagt, nicht ausprobiert.
Da habe ich von der ganzen Aufmachung her
schon
ein ziemlich schlechtes Gefühl bei.
Wisst ihr, was ich hier gerade gelesen habe?
Ich habe hier gerade gelesen, ähm
Du zockst die ganze Nacht,
Backforce kümmert sich um deine Blase.
Ich habe gedacht,
da ist irgendwie ein
Pissbeutel eingebaut oder so.
Das wäre doch mal,
das wäre doch mal was, oder?
Backforce kümmert sich um deine Blase.
Dual-Corsets.
Oh,
echter Sport.
Die Seite ruckelt.
Der von, oh was ein Gelaber.
Alter, Partner, ne?
Ob da der Niko auch drinsteht?
Ne, ne, ich glaube,
okay, die sind da anscheinend
voll begeistert von.
Aber ich bleibe bei meinem.
Ich bleibe bei meinem.
Ich war, wie gesagt, ich habe noch nie auf so einem guten Stuhl gesessen.
Ich war noch nie so lange zufrieden mit dem Stuhl am Stück,
ohne dass das Ding irgendwelche Probleme macht.
Da knarzt nichts, sonst was.
Das ist stabiles Metall,
hier die Sachen, also
das ist wirklich einfach
ein richtig nicer Stuhl.
Was ist hier los? Ah, der Bildschirmschoner.
Ah, yes, Bildschirmschoner.
Excellent.
Ich erwische mich manchmal, wie ich auf der Arbeit
so dummes Zeug vor mich hin labere.
Ich habe letztens irgendwas gemacht
am Laptop von unserem Azubi
und habe dann, habe dann Enter gedrückt
und habe irgendwie sowas, irgendwie sowas
laut vor mich hin gesagt, so nach dem Motto
Ah, yes, excellent.
Excellent.
Der hat nichts gesagt.
Er hat nichts gesagt, aber wahrscheinlich hat er sich gedacht,
dass der Alte total verrückt ist, der spinnt.
Das macht die Leute
fertig im Kopf hier.
Big Clan ist nicht mal bei Major dabei.
Ja, man muss nicht unbedingt
Weltklasse sein, um
einen Stuhl promoten zu können.
Ich mache das auch jedes Mal.
Ah, yes.
Ich habe eine ganz normale
Workstation-Lizenz.
Die habe ich vor ein paar Jahren an Weihnachten gekauft.
Die haben irgendwie so ein komisches Sale an Weihnachten immer.
Normalerweise kostet es was?
140 und an Weihnachten kostet es dann irgendwie nur
69.
Darf man fragen, wie alt du bist?
Ich bin vier, äh, excellent.
Ich bin 35.
Ich bin 1984 geboren. Ich musste gerade überlegen.
Ich wollte gerade 34, aber nein.
Es ist 35.
How many Chrome Tabs?
Aber das habe ich nicht als letztes
geguckt.
Okay, dann gucken wir.
Wir haben die Windows-Sachen
doch schon ausprobiert.
Wir haben im Büro dank unserem Business
Was? Dank unserer neuen
Business-Development-Managerin
Was macht man als
Business-Development-Managerin?
Ist sie auch agil?
Und ihr auch?
Seid ihr alle schön Agile?
Für agile
Multilevel-Speed-Architekturen
Zeig mal her.
Oh!
Da könnte ich nicht drauf sitzen.
Was ist denn das?
Ne.
Da würde ich mich weigern, ey.
Da tut dir ja alles weh
nach einem halben Tag.
Das ist so ein Stuhl, wo ich mich nicht vorstelle.
Der hat doch nicht mal Armlehnen.
Wie zum Teufel will man
mit einem Stuhl arbeiten,
der keine Armlehnen hat?
Wie soll das gehen?
Ach, man sitzt da so rum drauf.
Da komme ich aber
gar nicht richtig an die Tastatur.
Ich bin skeptisch, ob
das was taugt.
Du sollst nicht arbeiten, sondern
ökonomisch sitzen. Tja.
Taugt das echt was?
Ich will es dir zwar nicht schlecht
reden. Taugt das jetzt ernsthaft?
Wieso sind die so
teuer? Weil Design.
Interessiert dich
Aktien-Finanz-Thema?
Prinzipiell schon.
Ich muss mich unbedingt mehr mit
der ganzen Sache mal auseinandersetzen,
weil ich habe so viel Kohle einfach
sinnlos rumliegen.
Bis auf ein paar wenige Sachen,
dass es eher weniger wird.
Und das suckt.
Was für ein Smartphone hast du?
Welches wüsstest
du denn gerne?
Okay, bleiben wir mal smart.
Also mein Smartphone, was ich täglich verwende,
ist ein iPhone XS.
Ich habe kein Android. Ja, das kommt.
Man findet ihn immer überraschend.
Dafür habe ich jede Menge andere Android-Geräte.
Aber was Smartphones angeht,
ähm...
Es hat mehrere
Gründe, warum ich ein iPhone habe. Hauptsächlich,
weil ich es nicht selbst bezahlen muss.
Welche Unterhosen trägst du?
Ich kann dir sagen, welche Unterhosen ich nicht
trage. Ich habe mal den Fehler
gemacht, mir vor einem Jahr oder so
Markenunterhosen zu kaufen.
Und jetzt weiß ich auch, warum
Hugo Boss nicht umsonst auf dem absteigenden
Ast ist.
Die waren der allerletzte Scheiß.
Die sind nach
einmal waschen kaputt gegangen.
Der Gummi.
Wirklich, nach einmal waschen, Gummi im Arsch.
Löcher, Löcher
zwischen Gummi und...
Der allerletzte Crap.
Und sogar noch relativ teuer. Also das
werde ich nie wieder kaufen.
Gummi im Arsch. Oh, der Chat wieder.
Der Chat, Alter.
Welche Grafikkarte hast du? Ich habe immer noch
1080 TI.
Okay. How many Chrome Tabs can you open?
Das gucken wir uns noch an.
Wir wollten uns das Video das letzte Mal schon angucken.
Reddit Finanzen Starter Kit.
Ist das, ist
das, äh,
empfehlenswert, ja.
Kappa HD.
Max ist in FFM an der Quelle
und kommt nicht ins Stonks Game.
Ja, man muss sich für das Stonks
Game auch interessieren.
Äh, Moonvi, zwei Monate.
Dankeschön. Huge Sub.
Bist du mit deinem Single-Leben zufrieden
oder möchtest du schon mal jemand haben?
Oh, das Thema hatten wir schon öfters.
Das Thema hatten wir schon öfters.
Wenn ich, wenn ich davon jetzt wieder anfange.
Äh, prinzipiell schon.
Aber,
ich finde,
wer sich noch, erinnert sich noch einer an das
Weihnachtsgrill von vor
zwei Jahren? Ich finde
zwischenmenschliche Sachen einfach unglaublich
anstrengend.
Sodass ich mich, sodass ich halt
alles schleifen lasse, ja.
Legende, ja.
Ich kümmere mich um
zwischenmenschliche Beziehungen einfach nicht.
Also sprich, selbst,
selbst Leute, die ich eigentlich
gern hab und, ähm,
mit denen ich auch gerne
was machen würde, ich kümmere mich da nicht drum.
Ich finde zwischenmenschliche
Beziehungen sehr, also
extrem, äh,
unmotivierend für mich so.
Das ist, ich weiß, dass ich da
nicht, also ich bin nicht der Einzige und ich weiß aber auch,
dass ich garantiert nicht zu der Mehrheit
gehöre. Das sehe ich
ja auch immer, wie viele Leute gerne
auf das Sommerfest gehen, auf die
Weihnachtsfeier gehen oder sonstige Geschichten
auf der Arbeit machen und irgendwelche
Aktivitäten danach oder am Wochenende
irgendwelche großartige Action machen oder sonst was.
Für mich ist das anstrengend. Ich mach
keine, ich,
zwischenmenschliche Sachen sind für mich, äh,
anstrengend.
In den Weebspam gehe ich,
den Weebspam, das erste, wenn ich morgens den
Discord aufmache, ich guck morgens, wenn ich auf die Arbeit komme,
mal in Discord, was die Leute wieder so rumgespammt
haben. Das erste, was ich mache, ist
den Weebspam rechts
anklicken und sagen, als gelesen markieren.
Dass ich nicht aus Versehen auf die Idee
komme, da reinzuklicken.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt nochmal das Video an. Das wollten wir uns das letzte
Mal schon angucken.
Max ist Autist.
Also ich glaube auf der Autismus-Skala,
wenn es sowas gäbe,
bin ich auf jeden Fall, ähm,
in diese Richtung.
Aber es fehlt noch einiges dazu.
Ah, ja, ja. So, gucken wir uns mal
das Video an. Würdest du sagen,
dass Streamen gleich Arbeit ist? Nö.
Auf der PPGa-Skala.
Oh, da bin ich ganz schön weit oben.
Oh, Sellout.
Sellout am Start.
Ist aber echt kein Ding, 2TB.
Wir hatten vor Jahren schon Server mit 2TB.
Vor Jahren.
Also sprich, dort, wo noch kein DDR4
oder sonst was ist.
Es war wirklich lange her.
Da hatten sie quasi
64G-Module drauf.
Und
der Witz ist, wenn man
2TB sieht,
mit 64G-Modulen,
das sieht
enttäuschend aus.
Man denkt jetzt, man macht die Abdeckung auf
von der Kiste und das ganze Ding ist
voller RAM. Und im Endeffekt,
hat es einfach auch nur vorne ein paar RAM-Bänke mehr.
Meinung dazu, dass uBlock
Origin jetzt die IP-Adresse auslesen
will, beziehungsweise sie breche.
Hab ich gesehen, hab ich mir keine Gedanken zugemacht.
Äh,
gibt's dazu irgendwas?
Hab ich mir keine Gedanken zugemacht.
Was sagen die denn dazu?
Ja, das ist doch sinnvoll.
Ja, kann man machen. Warum nicht?
Schadet nix.
1TB bietet in der Nähe
16 Memory-Schlüsseln.
Also, Schritt 1 dann,
brauchen wir
etwas sehr besonderes.
Ein einziger Stick
von diesem RAM
hat mehr Kapazität
als euer gesamtes System.
Einer dieser
ist 128GB
von Memory.
Okay, da reichen ja 16 sogar.
Ähm,
ansonsten hättest du halt 32 gebraucht
für 64-G-Module.
Der hat den Sellout einfach schon im Blut.
Es macht...
Also ich finde, Dance Gaming macht immer super
Sellouts eingebunden in seinen Let's Plays
und Linux schafft einfach
die Überleitung immer sehr
weich zum Sellout.
So that's where all the
traces that you see running between
your memory slots and your CPU
socket come into play.
Now there are two ways that you can increase
the capacity of a memory module.
You can add more chips
by putting them on both sides
or by double stacking them
like we see here or
you can actually engineer the chips
themselves with more data
areas or ranks.
A dual rank
memory module might have exactly
the same...
Ist mir eigentlich vollkommen wurscht.
Hauptsache das Ding hat's...
...number of visible chips
soldered onto it, but it's
effectively like smushing
two single rank modules into
a single slot and a quad rank
module is like stuffing
four modules into a single slot.
Which is pretty cool
if you need more capacity, but
it causes a small problem.
The memory controller on
a given CPU has a limited
number of ranks that it can be
able to run into directly before
performance starts to drop off or
it reaches a hard limit.
So you might run into cases in the
server world where even though
a motherboard has, you know, let's say
16 slots, you could populate
all of them with dual rank modules
or only half of them with
quad rank modules and then
running at a reduced speed.
There's not much point in
doubling your memory density if
you cut away half of your expansion
slots and some speed, right? Like, that's not the point.
That's classic. One step forward,
two steps back.
So we're getting around that problem
using what's called load-reduced
or LRDIMS and there is a lot
of engineering packed into these.
They run at a blistering 2933
megahertz, so that is the rated
speed of our AMD EPYC 64-core
processor and they have both
a ninth chip
in each one of these rows
ECC or error correction
and
an extra memory buffer chip
that allows the processor's
memory controller to operate in
serial mode. This serial operation
causes a quad rank dim
to load the memory controller
like a dual rank dim
or an eight rank dim
to operate like a quad.
Ah, yes. Alles klar.
Excellent.
Deswegen habe ich den ganzen
RAM aus.
So, jetzt wird eingebaut.
Die Musik dabei.
Jetzt kriegen wir erzählt,
dass er die Gold-SSD verwendet.
Das ist in Korea.
Das heißt, man kann die Dinger
sich auch ohne Coronavirus bestellen.
Das mache ich auch gerne.
Ich würde das auch immer stylisch
stellen.
Ich habe hier auch noch
ein paar Sachen.
Ich finde es auch immer stylisch,
Mainboards anzuschalten
mit dem Schraubendreher anstatt
mit dem Schalter.
Das ist jetzt wirklich kein Witz.
Die alten IBM-Kisten,
die wir hatten,
die hatten nur,
in Anführungsstrichen,
96 GB RAM.
Das ist aber auch schon ein paar Jahre her.
Und die haben bei jedem Reboot
einen Memory-Check gemacht.
Die haben ohne Scheiß fünf Minuten gebootet,
bis es überhaupt angefangen hat,
ins Betriebssystem zu gehen.
Und wenn du da in den Bootmanager
immer musstest, im Crab
irgendwas einstellen und du hast nicht
die richtigen fünf Sekunden erwischt
innerhalb dieser fünf Minuten,
dann hast du keine Zeit mehr.
Es hat vielleicht lange genug gedauert
für eine Veränderung des Wardrobes.
LTT-Store.com
Was? Wir sind auf!
2.097.152 MB
von Memory,
mit 29,33 Millionen Transfers pro Sekunde,
64 Cores von Prozessor-Gutachten
und ich habe eigentlich einen coolen Tipp
von Gigabyte,
dass wenn du hier reinkommst
und all diese Warnungen ignorierst...
Was ich ja cool finde,
die Serverboard-BIOS-Dinger, die sehen immer noch so aus wie 1990.
Wohingegen die Consumer-Mainboard-BIOS-Oberfläche
ist ja schon ein bisschen fancier.
Ist ja auch schon mehr fancy.
Am besten würde ich sagen,
du guckst in irgendeinem
Hardware-Forum,
Computerbase zum Beispiel,
PC Master Race auf Reddit
oder nach aktuellen
Zusammenstellungen, die Leute gemacht haben.
Einfach mal ein bisschen umgucken,
was die Leute da aktuell empfehlen.
Ich bin da auch nicht auf dem Laufenden,
ich bin immer nur dann auf dem Laufenden,
was neue Desktop-Hardware angeht,
wenn ich mir selbst einen neuen Rechner kaufen will.
Ich könnte wahrscheinlich auch Chrome öffnen,
und es wäre immer noch 0%.
Bevor wir mit unserem ganzen Test weitergehen,
habe ich geplant,
wie viele Tabs wir beherrschen können.
Ich will mal schauen, wie die Leistung
mit unserer Konfiguration aussieht.
Es ist wichtig zu bemerken,
dass unser 64-Core-Prozessor
nicht SMT-entwickelt ist.
Es funktioniert nur mit 64 Threads.
Es ist ein bisschen eine Idiosynkrasie
von diesem Board,
aber es dauert nur 2,44 Sekunden.
Wir schauen also nicht,
wie die Leistung aussieht.
Ich glaube, dass es weniger Tabs sind,
als man denkt.
Man würde jetzt sagen,
da kannst du 5.000 Tabs aufmachen,
aber wahrscheinlich ist bei 300 Tabs
Schluss oder so was.
Wir müssen also eine gute Lösung finden,
um das so zu machen.
Brandon, schick mir ein paar Webseiten.
YouTube?
Ja, schick mir ein paar Neopets.
LinkedIn?
Was machst du da auf LinkedIn?
Oh, sie ist sicher, ja.
Hey, da ist er!
Oh nein, das ist ein schreckliches LinkedIn-Profil.
Okay, es scheint,
dass er sich aufhört.
Neue Gründe, oh, ich liebe es.
Und wir gehen jetzt zum MKB.
Der hat ganz schön was zu tun,
wenn er von Hand 5.000 Tabs aufmachen will.
Das ist mein Lieblings-Tab.
10 Millionen Zuschauer,
Chrome benutzt eigentlich
2,5 GB RAM,
und macht eigentlich nichts.
Es ist also
immer noch ein Vogel.
Es macht keinen Schmerz.
Es registriert nicht.
Es ist flatline.
Also, lass uns das machen.
Wir öffnen alle 20 Tabs in einem neuen Fenster.
Ja, das bin ich sicher.
Okay, wir sind von 5.000
zu 5.8.
Es ist schon lächerlich,
6 GB verbrauchen wir gerade.
Na klar,
der lädt jetzt ja auch den Kram erst.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Aber der wird die anderen Sachen dann wieder
freigeben.
Ja, genau, genau so.
So ungefähr dachte ich mir das.
This is super dumb.
I want a piece of paper.
You know, I'm gonna start tallying
how many tabs I'm opening.
I need paper.
Update for you guys.
At 200 Chrome Tabs,
we are now at 10 GB of RAM
and 1% usage.
600 Tabs, 700 Tabs,
900 Tabs,
1.000 Tabs.
5%.
This is interesting.
This seems to be our heaviest website.
First you take my youth,
then you take my CPU cycles.
We're up to 69%
CPU usage.
Well, I think we're gonna run out of CPU.
Die CPU macht nicht mit.
Naja, dann müsst ihr halt was anderes aufmachen.
Irgendwas, was kein JavaScript geschiss macht.
Wobei der ja eigentlich
die nicht aktiven Tabs
nach einer Weile suspenden sollte.
Mal gucken, was ihm einfällt.
We are over one stick of memory use now.
132 GB.
Chrome at least admits,
that it's using over 100 GB of RAM now.
Power usage very high.
5000 Tabs.
Here we go, boys.
Hey, we're at 10% RAM usage now.
So that's sick.
But what's interesting
is that in spite of us
having resources available to us,
the system is getting
slower and slower and slower
to the point where even when this ad managed to load...
Ja, das ist klar.
Es ist klar, dass es den Geist aufgibt.
Weil ich mein, im Hintergrund ist ja
jedes Tab ein eigener Thread.
Und
5000 aktive Threads für eine Anwendung
ist ja schon mal ne Hausnummer.
Die nicht irgendwie großartig
sleepen oder sonst was,
die auf sind.
Da würde ich sagen, das ist schon ordentlich.
Aber 500 jetzt, wenn wir schon 5000
im Hintergrund haben,
war wie das erste 500,
wenn wir es gemacht haben.
Jetzt ist das interessant.
Ich habe die Tabs wiedergearbeitet,
um das Thumbnail zu drehen.
Und wir haben einen Spalt in der CPU-Ausgabe.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob die Erinnerung
eigentlich verändert ist, aber
schaut euch das an. Ein paar dieser Tabs,
die schon geöffnet waren,
sind jetzt wieder aufgeladen.
Es scheint also, dass das Interagieren mit der Tür
es tatsächlich zu refreshen macht.
Das ändert nicht unsere RAM-Ausgabe.
Und weil das das ist, wofür wir sind,
glaube ich, dass das noch okay ist.
Oh oh.
Oh nein.
Wir hätten unser Limit erreicht.
Brandon!
Ich roll.
Wir hätten unser Limit erreicht, Brandon.
Aber ich will das Thumbnail bekommen.
Wenn ich es wieder öffnen muss,
um das verdammte Thumbnail zu bekommen,
wird es schmerzen.
6000.
Wir sind jetzt an dem Punkt,
in dem ein Tab,
das ich aus einem Browser-Window
zurückgezogen habe,
und es einfach nicht
verantwortlich genug ist, um es zu machen.
Oh, hey.
Es hat es geschafft. Okay.
Also haben wir das.
Ich meine, GIMP kann es öffnen,
also das ist cool.
Wir haben nur nur 200 GB
an Erinnerungsanwendung.
Und das ist nur aus dem Rearrangement
auf den Tab.
Auf Macbook ging mehr, okay.
Gut, dass es laggt,
wundert mich nicht.
Ja, wir haben jetzt nicht das Problem.
Okay.
Wie viel hat er? 6000 RAMs?
6000 Tabs?
Ja, das ist wirklich
nicht mehr so viel,
was in Google Chrome wirklich
verwendbar ist.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt es genossen,
mit uns auf der Reise zu kommen.
Ein großer Shoutout an SK Hynix
für das Sponsorieren dieses Videos.
Ja, das kann auch nur der machen.
Also, weil das ist halt teuer,
sowas zu machen.
Hatten wir heute Frametrops?
So gut wie keine.
Das heißt, Unity Media scheint zu funktionieren.
So in der Richtung müssen wir uns, glaube ich,
nicht angucken.
Okay, Leute, es ist 21.15 Uhr.
Das, was ich heute machen wollte,
habe ich schon längst erledigt.
Schon vor einer Stunde oder so waren wir durch.
Ich gehe jetzt auf.
Macht's gut, wir sehen uns die Tage.
Bis denn.
CU.